Sie lieben Mathe, Physik und ihren Computer. Ihre Telefonnummern gleichen oft geheim Codes. Sie tragen Hochwasserhosen kombiniert mit Jesus-Latschen. Sie haben ihr Zeichen und Körperpflege ist nicht so ganz ihr Metier. Es gibt sie in der ganzen Welt. In Japan heißen sie Otaku, in Finnland Nerdy, in vielen anderen Ländern wie auch bei uns heißen sie einfach Nerds.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 47. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier kommt schon wieder die Post. Neue Kunde aus den Technik-Welten und heute auch ein Novum. Ich bin nicht zu zweit, sondern ich bin zu dritt. Und zwar mit, ihr hört es schon am Kichern, mit Starbug zu meiner Rechten. Hallo Starbug. Und mit Constanze. Hallo. Ihr beide seid ja, ja, erstens seid ihr Experten, deswegen seid ihr hier. Spezialexperten, genau. Erstens seid ihr Spezialexperten, zweitens seid ihr eigentlich auch seit gut zwei, drei Jahren auch in der Öffentlichkeit ziemlich sichtbar geworden im CCC-Kontext, teilweise in Sprecherfunktionen, aber vor allem auch, was alle Fragen rund um Biometrie, das betrifft vor allem dich Starbug, betrifft aber auch Privatsphäre, Datenschutz, eigentlich der ganze Rattenspanz. Das bezieht dich auf jeden Fall auch noch mit ein. Könnt ihr denn feststellen, dass es in diesen Themenbereichen zu gehäufter Kommunikation gekommen ist in der letzten Zeit?
Gehäufte Kommunikation mit wem?
Mit der Außenwelt.
Oh ja, deutlich. Also seit eigentlich Wahlcomputer und dann halt Online-Desuchungen haben wir so massiven Anstieg an Presse-Kommunikation gehabt, dass es halt wirklich exorbitant ist. Eine Steigerung kann man nicht vergleichen mit früher.
Auch Anfragen für Vorträge im In- und Ausland über Themen, die hier in Deutschland massiv deportiert wurden, vor allen Dingen bei die Presse.
Unser Thema soll ja heute sein, der Elektronische Reisepass. Ich hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das Thema allerdings so ein bisschen nicht so auf der Skala ganz oben stand, was die Anfrage- und Diskussionsbereitschaft betraf, oder?
Na, das war so der Anfang, würde ich sagen, also wo unsere Pressearbeit so langsam losgegangen ist. Das Problem ist halt einfach, dass wir sicherlich auch ein bisschen spät eingestiegen sind und dass man auf der anderen Seite das ganze Verfahren, wie es halt eingeführt wurde, halt über die EU rüber, das relativ schwierig gemacht hat, dort noch irgendwie zu intervenieren.
Ja klar, der heute als europäischer Umweg bezeichnete Weg über die EU, der ist natürlich immer sehr schwierig, dann in Pressearbeit umzusetzen, wenn man ja keine Entscheidungen hat.
Der Umweg, den du beschreibst, ist der Umweg, dass wenn eine nationale Regierung nicht sieht, dass sie irgendwas Unpopulieres durchsetzen kann, dass sie dann einfach zur EU geht, dort ihr Gewicht in die Waagschale wirft, das zu einem EU-Beschluss machen lässt und den dann nur noch umsetzt.
Na, es ist sogar eigentlich noch ein bisschen expliziter. Also die EU-Umwege, die die Russen heute quasi so nennen, sind alles Entscheidungen, die der Bundestag schon abgelehnt hat, wie bei der biometrischen Vollerfassung. Und dann gibt es halt die EU-Innenministerrunde, wo die Inhalte der Richtlinien beschlossen werden und die Richtlinien, also die Richtlinien der EU, werden ja dann wieder runter auf die nationalen Parlamente gegeben und dann muss das ja umgesetzt werden.
Also man muss sich da mal vor Augen führen, dass diese Entscheidung, also gerade IPASS, im Endeffekt von fünf Leuten, also von fünf Innenministern aus der EU getroffen wurde. Also fünf Leute haben über 340 Millionen Europäer entschieden.
Warum sind das nur fünf?
Na, das ist halt die fünf größten. Also die haben sich halt zusammengesetzt, haben gesagt, wir machen dazu und dann haben natürlich alle anderen...
Also Deutschland, Britannien, Frankreich, Spanien...
Und Italien, glaube ich.
Und Italien. Das reicht schon aus.
Also fünf Leute, die auf die Art und Weise nicht mal demokratisch legitimiert wurden. Ich meine, sie sind zwar gewählt worden als Minister oder als Mitglied des Bundestages an die Regierung, der nationale Regierung gekommen, aber halt irgendwie diesen EU-Weg, den sie praktisch mit den Lokalen oder die nationalen Parlamente umgangen haben, da sind sie halt nicht demokratisch legitimiert. Aber im Endeffekt haben sie die Gesetze trotzdem durchgebracht.
Okay, vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen zurückspulen, worauf wir denn jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollen. Ich habe es ja schon angedeutet, elektronischer Reisepass. Eigentlich geht es um den Reisepass. Es gibt keinen zweiten, sondern der Reisepass wird jetzt elektronisch, bzw. ist bereits elektronisch geworden und wird jetzt noch etwas elektronischer. Vor allem wird er biometrischer und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum überhaupt die Elektronik eingeführt wird in den Pass. Ja, was ist denn da passiert? Wann wurde der erste Elektronische Reisepass offiziell eingeführt?
Das war im November letzten Jahres, also 1. November 2006, aber die Entscheidung war schon 2005, aber die eigentliche Entscheidung geht natürlich ein bisschen weiter zurück. Also ursprünglich, wo diese ganzen Gesetze aus den Schubladen gezogen werden, war natürlich im Nachklang vom 11. September. Und in Deutschland war das ganz speziell der Autokatalog 1, also von Herrn Schiedi da und danach nach Herrn Schiedi benannt. Das war Januar, Februar 2002 gewesen, wo der erste Autokatalog rausgekommen ist, der explizit auch schon darauf hingewiesen hat, dass die Reisedokumente sowohl mit Chip-Technik, als auch biometrisch aufgerüstet werden müssen, um die Falschungssicherheit zu erhöhen. Um Terroristen zu finden, war die offizielle Aussage dazu. Damals hieß es ja auch Terrorismusbekämpfungsgesetz.
Und biometrische Daten hieß in dem Zusammenhang zunächst einmal Gesichtsfelderfassung.
Zunächst einmal genau. Ein Bild des Gesichts. Das war schon eine internationale Übereinkunft, die eigentlich auf Drängen der USA damals gekommen ist, wo die USA gesagt hat, wenn ihr bis 2004 keinen elektronischen Reisepass habt, dann dürft ihr nicht mehr visafrei in die USA einreisen. Haben sie dann halt noch mal ein Jahr rausgeschoben, als halt klar wurde, dass es halt gar keiner umsetzen kann zu der Zeit?
Es gab sogar eine zweite Verlängerung. Also am Ende wurde um zwei Jahre sukzessive verlängert, sodass dann die europäischen Staaten, die nicht so schnell waren in der Umsetzung, noch die Frist halten konnten.
Aber dafür, dass das überhaupt so schnell durchgepeugt wurde, kann man schon feststellen, dass da auch eine ganze Menge Druck dahinter stand.
Ja, aber der Druck, also ich meine klar, initial war es halt die USA, aber dann haben auch sehr schnell die europäischen Länder beziehungsweise die Innenminister gemerkt, dass da halt auf jeden Fall Geld zu machen ist. Also ein Grund, also den Bier vermuten, was halt wirklich ein Grund im Endeffekt für die Einführung war, was halt inzwischen auch schon durch sich sickert, ist natürlich die Unterstützung der deutschen Wirtschaft. Also gerade die deutsche Wirtschaft ist halt auf dem Bereich der elektronischen Kartensysteme und halt auch der Biometrie halt schon mitweltführend. Und da ist halt auch relativ eindeutig, warum halt gerade diese Firmen von Herrn Schiedi da so gepusht wurden. Also ich meine, er sitzt jetzt inzwischen auch in Aufsichtsräten von zwei Biometriefirmen. Also dass da halt einerseits die deutsche Wirtschaft gefördert werden sollte und andererseits die ganze Problematik mit der Bundesdruckerei auch noch ein bisschen mit reingespielt hat, also die ja ehemals halt Staatseigenten privatisiert und dann auf ganz kruden Umwegen wieder so halb in Staatseigentum übergegangen ist, dass die halt mit Aufträgen für die Reisepässe irgendwie wieder liquidiert werden.
Was meinst du mit dieser quasi in den Staatseigentum übergegangen?
Na sie wurde halt sukzessive zurückgekauft. Also ich glaube, jetzt gehört sie der... Kannst du das auch sprechen? Hessische Landesbank, genau. Also die Verknüpfungen sind ja sehr kruder. Sie ist inzwischen nicht mehr wirklich vollständig.
Also durch Landesbanden wieder teilweise aufgekauft, um ein bisschen staatliche Kontrolle wieder zurückzuführen, wenn auch indirekt.
Na ja, also ich meine, sie haben es halt insofern verkackt, dass halt die Daten, die die Bundesdokerei einmal hatte, die sind jetzt natürlich aufgekauft worden. Also die haben natürlich die ganzen Daten der Bundesbürger einmal abgegriffen. Und im Endeffekt haben sie halt kein weiteres Interesse gehabt, die Bundesdokerei irgendwie finanziell aufrechtzuerhalten. Und für ein Staat ist es natürlich ziemlich blöd, wenn die ausstellende Behörde für Geldscheine und Passdokumente in ganz kruden ausländischen Besitzungen ist und es nicht darum gekümmert wird, dass sie halt finanziell auf der Höhe irgendwie mit ist, dass sie halt ihre Arbeit weiter fortsetzen kann.
Also die Bundesdokerei sollte diesen Reisepass realisieren.
Soll sie auch immer noch.
Soll sie auch immer noch und hat sie auch bereits getan.
Vielleicht noch einen Einwurf. Also es gibt inzwischen für die nahe Zukunft gibt es halt noch so eine Frage, ob es eine Ausschreibung für den Reisepass, den deutschen Reisepass geben wird. Also eine Neuausschreibung, dass halt nicht mehr die Bundesdokerei der alleinige Mitbieter ist, sondern zum Beispiel auch Gisiko und Deriwend. Das ist so eine bayerische Firma. Deriwend, genau, die halt auf jeden Fall so, wo halt die Idee zu dieser Ausschreibung auf jeden Fall aus Bayern kommt. Also da ist irgendwie Mr. Stoiber und wie sie alle heißen, da ganz oben mit dabei, weil sie halt sehen, dass da halt in Zukunft Geld zu machen ist und versuchen natürlich jetzt die Aufträge da aneinander zu ziehen.
Das ist auch irgendwie klar. Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo die Bundesdokerei als privates Unternehmen auftritt, fragt man sich natürlich, warum die und nicht irgendjemand anders?
Auf dem anderen Weg ist natürlich das Problem, dass wenn sie eine Ausschreibung machen, müssen sie eine EU-weite Ausschreibung machen. Und dann hat man vielleicht wieder das Problem, dass die Franzosen oder wer auch immer kommt und irgendwie da natürlich dann noch mitbieten und wie das bei EU-Ausschreibungen ist, im Endeffekt gewinnt dann der, der am meisten bietet, der am wenigsten für die Produkte bezahlen oder verlangen wird. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall geht es dann halt wieder verloren, aber nicht an irgendwelche Privatunternehmen, sondern halt an ausländische Großkonzerne.
Oder dann baut es jemand, der am wenigsten über die Sicherheit nachdenkt.
Das ist vielleicht noch eine andere Schiene, die oft vergessen wird. Man hat jetzt heute gerade in Europa immer diesen biometrischen E-Pass vor Augen, aber eigentlich gibt es bereits eine Entwicklung, die vor den Autokatalogen und vor dem 11. September stattgefunden hat. Und das ist dieses sogenannte System EuroDAC, was 2003 in Betrieb ging.
Die Euroente?
EuroDAC, also EuroDAC. Hier bezieht sich auf die Fingerabdrücke derjenigen, die nach Europa einreisen wollen.
Also was heißt EuroDAC?
Ich weiß nicht, wofür das Akronym steht, das ist ein System, was von der EU bereits 2000 in die Planung gegeben wurde. Zwar dann erst 2003 irgendwie in Kraft tat, aber die Asylbewerber in Europa waren immer dieses Testfeld für die biometrischen Anwendungen, sind es eigentlich auch heute noch. Die neuen Sachen werden immer ausprobiert über Asylbewerber, also die versuchen, nach Europa reinzukommen. So ein bisschen älter ist eben die biometrische Idee schon und prima ist eben an diesem Asylbewerber-Fingerabdrucksystem, dass die Biometriefirmen da ganz toll den Sicherheitsgewinn begründen konnten. Aber den Sprung zu machen und zu sagen, auch für den E-Pass bringt uns diese biometrische Vollerfassung mehr Sicherheit, die ist eigentlich nie begründet worden.
Okay, vielleicht, Tom, wir werden jetzt auch gleich mal ein bisschen in die Technik von dem E-Pass eintauchen. Ich habe gerade mal die allwissende Müllhalde befragt. EuroDuck steht für European Duck Thyloscopy. Ein automatisiertes Fingerabdruck-Identifizierungssystem.
Also vielleicht nochmal, warum Sie es tatsächlich einführen wollten, ist natürlich, also Europa schadet sich ja mehr und mehr zu... Die Biometrie für Ausländer mehr oder weniger, also für nicht Europäer. Ist natürlich, dass sich die EU gerade als erste Weltstaat oder irgendwie Ländervereinigung gegenüber der dritten Welt und der zweiten Welt halt natürlich abschirmen wird, was man halt irgendwie an den Grenzen zu gerade Afrika sehr deutlich sieht. Und die sind natürlich daran interessiert, dass sie Leute, die sie halt schon einmal abgewiesen haben, halt wieder erkennen können. Das heißt, wofür sie wirklich diese Fingerabdrücke nehmen, ist, dass sie Leute, also Asylbewerber, den Fingerabdruck nehmen, den wirklich dann zentral auch speichern, was irgendwie beim E-Pass nachher irgendwie noch mal eine andere Frage ist. Aber halt für die Ausländer, Asylbeantragten gilt halt zentrale Speicherung. Und halt, wenn sie halt das nächste Mal versuchen, wieder in die EU einzureisen oder halt Asyl zu beantragen, dann kann halt gesagt, wenn ihr wollt, schon mal abgewiesen, irgendwie geht mal weg irgendwie und werden halt wieder nach Afrika deportiert.
Das System läuft ja schon ziemlich lange, oder?
Es ist auch erfolgreich, muss man sagen, weil natürlich für diesen begrenzten Kreis von Menschen durchaus durch die Erfassung dieser Fingerabdrücke Sicherheitserfolge erzielt werden können, also erhöhte Abweisungen. Man muss sich halt nur überlegen, was diese daktyloskopische Erfassung für eine EU-Bevölkerung heißt, nämlich, dass es nur dann wirksam ist, wenn die gesamte EU-Bevölkerung biometrisch erfasst wird. Und genau das ist auch die Logik, die von diesen Asylbewerber-Fingerabdrücken rübergeholt wird auf die gesamte EU-Bevölkerung.
Also um das vielleicht noch mal runterzubrechen, was halt das Problem ist, dass EU-Bürger mit einem validen Pass ihren Pass an Afrikaner oder so weiterverkaufen, weitergeben und die Asylbewerber dann natürlich mit dem Pass in die EU einreisen können. Und das versuchen sie halt gerade mit dem Fingerabdrücken zu verhindern, dass halt an der Grenze festgestellt werden kann, der Passbesitzer ist nicht der Passinhaber. Das heißt irgendwie, irgendjemand hat ihnen seinen Pass gegeben oder der Pass wurde geklaut. Das heißt, wir können jetzt diese Person abweisen anhand der Fingerabdrücke.
Das heißt, der Elektronische Reisepass ist quasi eine Zwangsnotwendigkeit, nachdem man schon mal dieses Asylbewerbersystem eingeführt hat?
Das ist eine logische Konsequenz, also eine zusätzliche Funktion.
Na ja, natürlich ging es bei den Asylbewerbern auch darum, die Leute herauszufinden, die einfach zweimal an anderen Grenzen versuchen und sich einfach dann üblicherweise ohne Pass kommen und sagen, sie haben keinen mehr. Sie sind halt Flüchtlinge und aber ein neues Name oder ein neues Geburtsdatum angeben. Also die Begründetheit für dieses EU-Projekt der biometrischen Erfassung ist damit keineswegs gegeben. Also es wäre ja auch heute, da ja zwischendurch der 11. September waren auch ganz andere Sicherheitsargumente gebracht, als es früher die Begründung war.
Also die offizielle Begründung ist halt heutzutage oder war zumindest bei der Einführung auf jeden Fall halt, dass man damit Terroristen fangen kann. Also das haben sie auch so offen in der Pauschalität, in der Dummheit irgendwie so gesagt.
Ja gut, das ist ja das Argument für so ziemlich alles heutzutage, hat man so fast den Eindruck. Ja, vielleicht sollten wir uns mal ein bisschen noch näher anschauen, was biometrisch, ja wir machen mal, ich würde ganz gerne noch mal so kurz vielleicht beleuchten, bevor wir jetzt auf den E-Pass selber kommen, was eigentlich eure Einschätzung ist, was biometrisch derzeit eigentlich wirklich zu leisten ist. Es war in der ganzen Biometrie-Diskussion, da gibt es dann immer so zwei Flanken. Entweder sagt man, na ja, das ist alles ganz gefährlich, weil dann wird ja alles erfasst und dann haben wir den Big Brother. So und im selben Atemzug kommt dann aber auch häufig so dieses Argument, na ja, das kann man aber auch alles umgehen, das ist ja alles total unsicher und den Fingerabdruck kriegt man gefälscht und das funktioniert ja alles gar nicht. Also was ist denn die Realität jetzt an der Stelle? Funktioniert es und ist es irgendwie sicher im technischen Sinne oder funktioniert das gar nicht und bietet noch mehr Missbrauchspotenzial als die alten Systeme?
Also die Biometrie ist ja im Allgemeinen erstmal ein zusätzlicher Mechanismus, der hier verwendet wird. Das heißt irgendwie alles, was zusätzlich ist, kann es eigentlich nicht wirklich unsicherer machen, wenn man halt mal so von den, also wenn man halt wirklich nur die rein logische Betrachtungsweise sich anguckt.
Das verfeinert sozusagen.
Genau, also halt einfach zusätzliche Mechanismen, die man halt dann auch überwinden muss. Auf der anderen Seite hat man natürlich gerade, was die Erkennungsraten von zum Beispiel Gesichtserkennung betrifft, die sind halt so exorbitant schlecht. Also wir sind da teilweise so im Bereich von 50, 60 Prozent Erkennungsraten, wo man halt sagt, für die Kosten, die dort irgendwie aufgewendet werden müssen, um dieses ganze System zu etablieren, ist der Sicherheitsgewinn auf der anderen Seite so minimal, dass man es eigentlich nicht gegeneinander aufwerten kann.
Und wenn man dann annimmt, dass dieser Sicherheitsgewinn überhaupt stattfindet, da können wir ja dann später noch drauf kommen.
Okay, also es ist vor allem auch eine Kostenfrage, ob sozusagen der Aufwand getrieben werden muss.
Also gerade bei Biometrie ist es halt immer eine Frage, die man da auf jeden Fall gegenüber stellen muss. Also Biometrie an sich selber hat halt immer irgendwo einen gewissen Nutzen. Die Frage ist halt immer, wo man sie einsetzt. Also ob man sie halt so als Convenience-Fall einsetzt, also zur Vereinfachung von Verfahren, so als, also statt ein 1, 2, 3 als Passwort zu nehmen und lieber ein Fingerabdruck, da hat er sicherlich auch seine Berechtigung, die Biometrie. Allerdings halt, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel das Passwort komplizierter macht, wie es halt normalerweise irgendwie wir in unserem, in unserer Klientel zu tun, da bringt halt Biometrie halt genau einen gegenteiligen Nutzen, weil die Biometrie in dem Fall dann halt einfach schwächer ist als das starke Passwort.
Also das scheidet sich dabei natürlich ganz grundsätzlich von einer Smartcard oder von zum Beispiel einem Passwort, weil man natürlich ein Merkmal an dem Menschen zu kleben hat, da sind wir sein Gesicht oder eben seine Iris, sein Fingerabdruck. Man kann also kein Schlüssel verlieren, keine Smartcard und man kann kein Passwort vergessen. Insofern hat natürlich die Technik erst mal Vorteile. Aber im Gegensatz eben zum Beispiel zu einem Passwort, wo eben dieses eine Passwort stimmt, ist ein biometrisches Verfahren eher ein statistisch-mathematisches Verfahren. Das heißt, mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit kann man etwa einen Zugang erlangen. Und das ist natürlich dieser Technik erst mal innovant. Das heißt, es geht bei den normalen biometrischen Merkmalen wie Gesicht oder Fingerablob eben nur darum, eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit zu treffen. Es gibt natürlich biometrische Merkmale, die quasi perfekt sind. Und da haben wir aber momentan eigentlich nur eins, nämlich natürlich unser DNA.
Na, so ganz perfekt natürlich nicht. Also du hast niemals wirklich eine hundertprozentige Einstimmung, aber die kommen natürlich halt schon relativ gut an ein Passwort mit einer hundertprozentigen Wahrscheinlichkeit ran. Allerdings dann halt auch wieder die Probleme auf der anderen Seite, dass gerade DNA zum Beispiel sehr lange dauert, dass man dort halt auch sehr viele Zusatzinformationen eventuell preisgibt.
Also sehr lange dauert die zu gewinnen, also man kann jetzt nicht irgendwo ein Finger reinhalten und dann hat man gleich den genetischen Code.
Genau, also halt das muss dazu haben, was man dann halt nachher zum Abgleich, zur Verifikation benutzt.
Man kann nicht einfach ein Finger irgendwo auf den Sensor legen, sondern das ist natürlich viel langwieriger. Ich wollte damit nur betonen, dass die normalen biometrischen Merkmale eben einfach ein Wahrscheinlichkeitsverfahren sind und eins eben anders ist, aber gut.
Okay, da können wir auf jeden Fall noch mal drauf zu sprechen. Da sollten wir mal ein bisschen schauen, was jetzt in diesem Elektronischen Reisepass eigentlich tatsächlich drin ist. Wir haben es ja schon angesprochen, es gibt zwei Stufen. Stufe 1 wurde Ende 2005 bereits aktiviert. Das heißt, das Foto, was in dem Reisepass ist, korrigiert mich, wenn ich es falsch sage, ist nicht nur so ein Foto und wird nicht nur grafisch wiedergegeben, wie man das sonst so kennt, sondern es ist aufgerastert und es wird bereits bei der Erstellung des Passes ein biometrisches Profil erstellt, was dann in diesem Gerät, in diesem Pass gespeichert ist.
Ne, das ist nicht so. Also was da tatsächlich gespeichert wird, ist ein Foto, also kein Halbprofil-Foto, wie es halt früher viel ausweisbarer Pässe war, sondern ein Frontalfoto, das ist der Biometrie zu verdanken oder geschuldet. Aber die tatsächliche biometrische Auswertung findet noch nicht statt. Also es wird derzeit wirklich nur ein Foto gespeichert. Also das Foto wird vorher überprüft, ob es halt dem biometrischen Anforderungen theoretisch genügen würde, also ob die Augen Abstand groß genug ist, keine Kopfbedeckung, also keine wichtigen Teile.
Den Augenabstand kann man doch nicht kontrollieren.
Na doch, durch die Auflösung des Bildes. Also die Pixelzahl zwischen den Augen ist ja ein festes Fogelang.
Sie haben nicht genug Pixel zwischen den Augen.
Da können wir ja gleich mal einen konkreten Fond erzählen. Wir hatten im Clubumfeld gerade mal so einen Fall von jemand, der darüber berichtete, der brauchte einen neuen Pass und ging zum Fotografen und machte sich da so ein Frontalfoto und ging dann mal zum Meldamt und die Meldbeamtin sagte zu ihm, ne, tut mir leid, also diese passt nicht in unsere Raste. Die haben ja so eine Software, wo sie halt checken können, ob dieses Frontalfoto eben valide ist und ob sie es für die Algorithmen...
Also, sie nehmen das dann ein und dann...
Es gibt Mustertafeln oder Schablone, die halt sagen, wo die Augen liegen müssen, in welchem Abstand, wie hoch der Kopf sein darf und das hat halt bei ihm nicht funktioniert.
Sieht der denn irgendwie komisch aus?
Ja, er sieht ein bisschen komisch aus. Er sagt von sich selber, er hätte einen Eierkopf. Ich persönlich finde natürlich, er hätte überhaupt keinen Eierkopf, aber sei mal dahingestellt. Auf jeden Fall ging er zurück zum Fotografen, wie ihm geheißen wurde, und sagte, hm, ich habe ein Problem mit dem Passbild, das geht irgendwie nicht. Da sagte der Fotograf, gar kein Problem, machen wir ihn. Und machte halt ein Foto und hatte nachher mit dem Programm, mit einem Bildbearbeitungsprogramm, würde ich mal sagen.
Den Eierkopf gestaucht.
Er hat, genau. Entsprechend kam er also mit einem digital veränderten Foto zum Meldeamt, und die Beamtin hat dann zu ihm gesagt, ja toll, das nehmen wir. Entsprechend kann er natürlich von den biometrischen Erkennungsalgorithmen so nie erkannt werden, weil es ist nicht seine Kopfform.
Es sei denn, die funktionieren schlecht.
Das war natürlich, wir haben darüber sehr herzlich nachdenken müssen, aber natürlich kann heute ein Beamter nicht mehr erkennen, ob dieses Foto digital nachbearbeitet wurde für Menschen.
Und das ist auch Gang und Gäber mittlerweile bei den Passfotografen.
Ich meine, das sieht schon noch so aus.
Das ist aber immer verboten. Man darf laut Passgesetz, ja ja, natürlich, es ist halt die Umsetzung, weil halt irgendwie die Köpfe, also die Menschen sich nun mal nicht alle in dieses Raster quetschen lassen. Laut Vorgabe darf man halt die Auflösung oder die XY-Pixelgröße irgendwie nicht verändern. Aber da sie halt irgendwie nicht reingepasst haben und sonst keinen Pass kriegen würden, ist die logische Konsequenz, dass es halt einfach gestaucht wird in dem Fall.
Er konnte ja auch nichts machen in dem Fall. Das heißt, er konnte sich aussuchen, entweder keinen Pass zu haben oder noch fünfmal eben zur Fotografie zu gehen.
Also das heißt, es gibt einfach Kopfformen, die passen nicht in das amtliche Biometrierasser.
Das ist denen auch klar, aber sie haben halt ausgerechnet, es sind vielleicht 0,2 Prozent. Das heißt, das spielt jetzt irgendwie keine Rolle, weil es unter ein Prozent ist.
Also wir halten fest, das Foto wird selbst nicht analysiert. Also es wird nicht schon mal runtergebrochen auf bestimmte, noch nicht, also zumindest derzeit nicht, sondern es wird nur irgendwie fischig festgestellt, dass es wohl theoretisch biometrischen Anforderungen genügt. Und dann kommt es da rein. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe so einen Pass noch gar nicht gesehen. Ist da auch ein Raster auf dem Foto selber zu sehen? Nein.
Also der Pass selber sieht halt eigentlich identisch aus mit dem, den man vorher gekriegt hat, also vor 2005.
Außer, dass er so ein kleines Chip-Logo vorne drauf hat.
Genau, hat so ein komisches kleine Chip-Logo drauf. Und ansonsten ist es halt genau das gleiche. Du hast halt weiterhin dein Passbild drauf. Du hast irgendwie deine Karte da drinnen, die halt irgendwie dein Name und deine Geburtstatum, was auch immer irgendwie weiterhin auch auf analogen Weise irgendwie dort abgebildet hat. Aber du hast halt zusätzlich irgendwie all diese Informationen nochmal in dem Chip selber gespeichert.
Also man kann den nicht nur von außen erkennen an diesem kleinen Signum auf der Passdecke oben, sondern man kann ihn natürlich immer daran erkennen, wenn man die kleine Plastikkarte sieht, weil er jetzt ein Frontalfoto zu sehen ist. So kann man zum Beispiel auch den Kinderpass unterscheiden. Der Kinderpass hat ja keinen RFID-Chip, aber man sieht natürlich immer am Frontalfoto, dass es jetzt ein biometrisches Foto ist, weil es eben kein Halbprofil mehr ist.
Vielleicht sollten wir erst mal auf den Chip jetzt eingehen.
Genau, das wäre nämlich meine nächste Frage gewesen. Chip, das ist ja immer so toll. Ich liebe dieses Wort Chip. Man kennt das immer aus diesem Film, wenn dann, oh ja, er hat den Chip kopiert und so weiter. Wir haben auch hier wieder so einen geheimnisvollen Chip. Wo befindet sich der und worum handelt es sich dabei?
Also er ist in der PAS-Decke, nicht in dem PAS-Deckel, sondern in der PAS-Decke, wo sie immer ganz speziell drauf beharren.
Was heißt Decke?
Es ist der Deckel. Aber sie sagen, es ist nicht der Deckel, sondern es ist die Decke.
Das nicken meine Journalisten, weil die immer Deckel schreiben. Und die Bundesdruckerei liegt immer großem Wert darauf, dass es eine Decke ist.
Okay, alles klar.
Also wirklich in dem Papp-Buschlag, wo außen diese schöne Weinrot draußen rum ist, ist in der Vorderseite eine Plastikkarte. Genau an der Stelle, wo das Logo ist? Nee, irgendwie in einer von den Vierecken. Also wo jetzt genau, so halbwegs in der Ecke, so irgendwie so ein Zentimeter von jedem Rand ungefähr weg ist.
Hat das einen besonderen Grund, dass er da ist, wo er ist?
Das ist halt so Standard. Also man muss natürlich sagen, der Chip selber ist ja nur der Chip, wo die Daten aufgespeichert sind. Die Energie und die Kommunikation findet halt über die Antenne statt. Das heißt, man hat halt den Chip selber vielleicht einmal ein Millimeter groß ist, an dem halt eine Antenne dran gelötet oder dran gebondet ist, die halt einmal außen um die gesamte Größe oder fast die gesamte Größe des Passes geht.
Okay, das heißt, jetzt sind wir auch schon beim technischen Spezifikation. Es handelt sich natürlich um einen RFID-Chip, also nicht nur um irgendeinen Chip, wie er in jedem Computer drinsteckt, sondern um einen, der halt selber keine Energieversorgung hat, sondern er bekommt, ist ein passiver, hat also keine Batterie. Das ist, denke ich, zwei auch super, nicht? Wenn man noch seine Batterie tauschen müsste, bevor man irgendwie in Urlaub geht. Genau, Sie dürfen nur eine staatlich geprüfte Batterie nehmen. So, passiv heißt, dass das Auslesen selber führt zu Funkstrahlen, die den Chip überhaupt erst aktivieren. Und ja, was kann man jetzt mit diesem Chip machen? Also der wird, werkseitig wird er ja mit den Daten beladen. Da steht letztlich genau das Gleiche drin, was dort auch gedruckt ist. Oder steht da irgendwas drin, was nicht gedruckt vorliegt?
Naja, momentan, der, der jetzt ausgegeben wird, hat schon dieselben Daten auf dem Chip. Aber natürlich jetzt, ab 1. November, ist ein Unterschied, denn der Fingerabdruck ist ja nicht aufgedruckt auf dem Pass, sondern nur an dem Chip.
Also es sind zusätzlich noch kryptografische Schlüssel draufgespeichert. Also die halt die Daten signiert nochmal selber. Also vielleicht einfach mal irgendwie, um das klar zu machen, was wirklich gespeichert ist. Also in dem derzeitigen Pass sind die Pass-ID gespeichert. Also halt die Passnummer, das Geburtsdatum, der Name und das Ablaufdatum. Also so an den Daten, die auf dem Pass selber aufgedruckt sind. Dann ist noch das Gesichtsbild gespeichert. Also ein Foto. In dem Fall ist es ein JPEG 2000 komprimiertes. Das heißt also die Daten, das ist halt zwar eine Wiedergabe, aber halt schon komprimiert. Das heißt, das sind nicht die identischen Daten, sondern halt komprimierte Daten des Gesichtsbildes.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich dieses Frontalfoto in einer sehr guten Qualität gespeichert.
Also interessant, ich habe irgendwie gerade vor ein paar Tagen mir die Richtlinie durchgelesen, die vom Bundesrat kam halt über den Elektronischen Reisepass. Und was sie halt sagen, ist, dass die Größe der Gesichtsbilder beschränkt ist auf 18K. Das heißt, wenn die Komprimierung des Gesichtes auf wundersame Weise irgendwie ein 19K-großes Bild liefert, dann müssen sie halt wirklich den Komprimierungsalgorithmus neu, also mit anderen Parametern füttern, dass halt im Endeffekt das Bild irgendwie diese 18K-Gruß unterschreitet.
Mehr Platz ist halt nicht.
Das heißt, wenn man, also jetzt mal...
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine Akne hat und irgendwie die Kompression...
Oder einen bunten Haarschopf. Man kann im Endeffekt nichts mehr über die tatsächliche Bildqualität aussagen, weil sie halt eine feste Dateigröße vorgegeben haben. Das heißt, wenn man zum Beispiel mehr anderen auf der Hintergrund irgendwie Fraktale hat, die dann halt irgendwie komprimiert werden müssen, dann hat man eventuell ein Bild, was auf zwei Pixel besteht.
Fraktale auf dem Hintergrund des Bildes sind nicht erlaubt.
Sofern sie erkannt werden von den Beamten.
Und wenn man jetzt so... Wie ist denn das mit der Haartracht? Gibt es denn Aussagen darüber, wie die Haartracht zu sein hat?
Also sie dürfen nicht zu stark ins Gesicht fallen, die Haaren. Also mit der kleinen Ausnahme für männliche Gesichtshachen.
Also wenn die jetzt alle abstehen, so rundherum, wie so der gemeine Punk das so macht? So ein Sonnenschein-Frisur, so rundherum, wo man dann so...
Die dürfen dann nicht komplett im Bild sein. Also es gibt halt feste Definitionen für die Größe des Gesichts.
Nein, ich hab nicht so eine Frisur, aber ich meine, ich stell mir das gerade nur so vor, man würde dann so... Was soll das so aussehen, wie so ein kleiner Sonnenschein?
Damit würde ja da nicht aus den Kanten des Bildes fallen. Man hat ja immer Gesicht in einer gewissen Größe. Also wenn dir die Haare einen Meter abstehen, ist das für das Passbild relativ egal.
Vielleicht fäll ich mal wirklich schrittweise kurz, was die Anforderungen für ein Bild sind. Es ist halt irgendwie die Größe 32 bis 36 Millimeter. Dann halt das Gesicht muss zentrisch sein. Vom Kinn bis zum Haaransatz muss halt alles abgebildet sein. Der Kontrast muss halt stimmen, die Ausdeuchtung im Hintergrund usw.
Das ist recht wichtig. Da achten sie auf den Meldeamt auf, dass diese homogene Lichtsituation von allen Seiten dieses Bildes, zum Beispiel Schatten an den Nasen oder so, da gucken sie richtig drauf.
Das ist halt auch extrem wichtig für die nachher biometrische Auswertung. Genau diese Schatten würden nachher den Biometrie, also den Algorithmus total aus dem Gleichgewicht bringen. Zum Beispiel wie auch Brillen, zum Beispiel Sonnenbrillen sind verboten.
Aber Brillen sind nicht generell. Ich meine, wenn man diese Brille trägt? Doch.
Es steht explizit so drinnen, dass Rahmen, die sehr hervorstechen, nicht erlaubt sind. Und es ist natürlich auch klar, woher das kommt. Wenn du eine Hornbrille träger bist, musst du im Zweifelsfall deine Brille abnehmen für den Pass. Wenn du die dann an der Grenze wieder trägst, dann wird der biometrische Algorithmus sagen, du bist nicht die gleiche Person, weil du hast da so einen dicken, schwarzen Balken um deine Augen herum.
Die Strategie für einen CCC könnte eventuell sein, in zwei Jahren eine schöne Hornbrille, sind Hip-Kampagne zu los hier.
Die original CCC-Hornbrille, ich sehe es schon kaum. Also mit anderen Fraktalmustern.
Wo wir alle so schön lachen, gerade im Gesichtsausdruck, das ist das, was die größte Kritik oder eine sehr explizite Kritik an diesen neuen Passbildern war, da ist sowas wie Lachen verboten. Also wenn man tatsächlich zum Start geht und einen neuen Pass beantragt, dann ist sowas wie Humor im Endeffekt, also Lachen ist halt verboten.
Es geht ja auch um Sicherheit.
Neutralen geschlossenen Mund mit neutralen Gesichtsausdruck.
Das heißt, wenn jemand recht freudig ist, dann wird er eigentlich nie erkannt werden?
Es gibt damit auch ernsthaftere Probleme. Man muss sich überlegen, dass es einen Anteil der Bevölkerung gibt, die haben Behinderungen und die betreffen zum Beispiel die Gesichtsmuskulatur. Und solche Menschen haben da natürlich richtige Probleme damit. Die können zum Beispiel ihr Gesicht nicht entzerren, wenn ich es mal nenne. Das gibt es. Und zwar natürlich wieder nicht viele Menschen. Man kann immer sagen, naja, bloß ganz wenige. Aber auch solche, etwa Spassmen, gibt es. Also Menschen mit einer Kinderlähmung haben da große Probleme mit. Die haben sie jetzt schon auf dem Mädeamt häufig, weil sie damit auch schon heute Ärger haben, weil sie die Passbilder, die sie mitbringen, dann nicht anerkannt bekommen. Aber da gibt es natürlich wieder einen Anteil von Menschen, die dadurch echte Probleme kriegen. Und natürlich dazuzählen auch diese Leute, die aus religiösen oder kulturellen Gründen ohnehin nicht, genau, also die kein offenes Gesicht präsentieren wollen, auch nicht auf dem Foto.
Das ist übrigens, soweit ich weiß, ich glaube, es wurde noch nie wirklich durchgesetzt, derzeit so ein Verfahren ist es verboten, tatsächlich mit einer Boca oder mit einer Vollgesichtsschutz oder wie auch immer, sich einen Pass zu holen. Also in Deutschland muss man, also man darf Kopftuch tragen, aber...
Verbündet dich das?
Nö. Aber ist natürlich... Nee, aber man muss natürlich halt sowas wie Religionsfreiheit dann den Sicherheitsinteressen, den Sicherheitsinteressen anführungsfähig des Staates mal gegenüberstellen. Und da haben sie halt ganz klar in den Gesetzen geregelt, dass Kopftuch prinzipiell erlaubt ist, aber halt nur bis zum Haarensatz. Und es darf keine Schatten ins Gesicht werfen. Du meinst Hornbrille und ganz Körper. Du meinst der ganze Prenzlauer Berg.
Verbockert. Ich bin gespannt. Na gut, wir waren beim Chip. Und was darauf gespeichert war, das Bild ist in irgendeiner Auflösung, wie viele Pixel immer Pixel sind denn das dann in etwa? 18 Kilobyte. Also gut, dann muss man jetzt, diese 18 Kilobyte beziehen sich auf nach der Kompression. JPEG 2000 ist sehr effizient.
Also es waren genau 300 DPI, muss es eingescannt sein in der Qualität. Und es muss mit 600 DPI wird es ausgedruckt im Endeffekt. Also das heißt, das Foto...
300 DPI in Bezug auf 32 Millimeter oder was. Ja, was kann ich denn dafür, dass ihr so spät kommt? Da muss man auch mal ein bisschen gännen dürfen zwischendurch. Wir sitzen nämlich mitten in der Nacht. Ja, ich kann ehrlich gesagt gleich mal Mate holen. Das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Oder ein Schunk.
Nee, wir machen keinen Break. Du erklärst einfach gleich mal was ganz Sinnvolles und ich hole Mate. Aber kurz noch zu Ende. Also du sagst 32 Millimeter bis 36 Millimeter sollen die Bilder was? Breit, lang?
Breit, genau. Also Höhe mal Breite ist...
32 mal 36. Und das damit 300 tp.
300 tp und der Abstand zwischen Augen ist halt noch so eine Vorgabe, soll halt mindestens 90 Pixel sein. Weil halt einfach sonst die Auflösung zu gering ist für die...
Weil da sieht man jetzt schon, was sozusagen wichtig ist.
Einen ganz kurzen Einwurf, es sind 15 Kilobyte, nicht 18. Um das jetzt mal genau zu sagen.
Okay, 15 Kilobyte, wir wiederrufen alles, was wir wissen.
Genau, 18, 18 war die Fingerdrucke, kommen wir nachher nochmal zu.
Es ist dann einfach damit klar, dass die Qualität dieses biometrischen Gesichtsbittes schon eine gute ist. Das hört sich jetzt relativ wenig an. Aber insgesamt ist das schon eine Qualität, mit der man mit Erkennungsergehorten gut arbeiten kann. Das muss man sehen, in einer guten Qualität natürlich. Wenn die Anforderungen, die dort festgeschrieben sind, jetzt im Passgesetz so umgesetzt werden, ist das nicht schlecht.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für ein Chip? Entspricht der irgendeinem Standard?
Genau, also das ist, um jetzt mal ein paar Zahlen hier uns euch an den Kopf zu werfen, ist ein ISO-14443-Chip, arbeitet auf der Frequenz von 13,56 MHz. Das ist halt so eine gängige RFID-Frequenz. Es ist eine Proximity Card, das heißt eine Auslesereichweite laut Spezifikation von 10 cm. Dazu muss man natürlich sagen, dass diese Spezifikationen auf definierte Feldstärken des Lesegeräts definiert sind. Das heißt, wenn man zum Beispiel die Leistung des Lesegeräts hochschraubt, dann kann man sehr wohl da auch irgendwie Reichweiten von 50 cm oder so etwas auf jeden Fall locker erreichen. Und natürlich, also das aktive Ansprechen, ich glaube auf die passiven Auslesen werden wir später mal noch eingehen. Also man kann halt das Lesegerät so optimieren, dass man halt den Pass selber auf größere Distanzen als vorgesehen auslesen kann. Also was ja das ein Angriffsszenario ist, dass man halt zum Beispiel den Pass halt auslesen kann in der Tasche des Opfers, wo halt das BMI, also das Innenministerium irgendwie immer sagt, ja aber laut Standard sind ja nur 10 cm zulässig. Das heißt, man muss irgendwie seinen Leser schon an die Tasche des Opfers halten. Aber natürlich muss man sich als jenige, der den Pass auslesen will, unberechtigt, natürlich nicht an den Standard halten. Da kann man sehr wohl auch die Leistung hochdrehen. Kann man halt Antennen benutzen, das heißt, man kommt da halt schon deutlich über diese 10 cm darüber raus.
Das ist ja das Schöne an Passive Air, weil die Energie, mit der es ausgelesen wird, kommt von außen. Das heißt, wenn man die entsprechend dimensioniert, dann liegt die halt auch vor.
Offenbar ist diese kleine Problematik unserem BKA-Chef Jörg Zierke schon bekannt, denn der trägt seinen biometrischen Reisepass mit einer Schutzhülle.
Woher weißt du denn das?
Das hat er offiziell zugegeben.
Ja, ich glaube, das war sogar im Bundestag diese Anhörung.
Die Anhörung zum Reisepass.
Dann hat er auch danach darüber geschrieben. Also, natürlich ist es nicht offiziell begründet worden, nach dem Motto, wir glauben, es sei unsicher, deswegen, aber er hatte halt eine Schutzhülle. Gegen sind ausgelesen.
Man muss sich einfach mal vor Augen halten, was das bedeutet. Also, dass halt tatsächlich diejenigen, die diesen Pass irgendwie eingeführt haben oder die für die Sicherheit mehr oder weniger mitverantwortlich sind, dass sie halt selber sehen, dass die Pässe halt so unsicher sind, dass sie sich selber schützen, indem sie halt extra Maßnahmen einleiten.
Aber gab es nicht beim Elektronischen Reisepass da noch so ein Last-Minute-Change, der dieses Aktivieren des Chips verhindern soll, wenn es nicht so eine...
Also, wir haben zur Technik weiter. Also, da kommen wir jetzt zu den Sicherungsmaßnahmen. Es gibt die sogenannte Basic Access-Control. Also, normalerweise kann man den Pass nicht auslesen. Also, wenn man halt jetzt den in der Tasche trägt und man den Pass vorher noch nie gesehen hat, dann ist es relativ unmöglich, dass man die Daten aus dem Pass auslesen kann.
Aber man kann sehen, da ist ein Pass.
Man kann sehen, da ist ein Pass, ja. Das heißt, man kann sehen, da ist ein RFID-Chip.
Da ist ein RFID-Chip, genau.
Und man kann auch sagen, da ist ein RFID-Chip, der wahrscheinlich ein ISO 14443...
Das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen.
Das ist aber ein sehr, sehr häufiger Standard.
Das heißt, das kann auch irgendwie schon die Einkaufstüte sein, die da irgendwie reagiert. Man weiß nicht unbedingt, dass es ein Reisepass ist.
Na, also vielleicht, also die Technik sagt, dass... Also halt, dass diese UID, also der RFID-Chip, hat einen eindeutigen Identifier normalerweise. Das ist die sogenannte UID, die halt... Jeden Chip eindeutig, der wird halt im Werk genau irgendwie auf diese UID festgesetzt. Das heißt, wenn man den einmal ausliest, dann sollte er eigentlich immer die gleiche UID zurückgeben. Unique Identifier, genau.
Also das heißt wirklich die eindeutige Kennzeichnung des einen Chips.
Was ihm natürlich bei der Einführung des Passes dann irgendwann irgendwie in den Sinn gekommen ist, dass das natürlich eine ganz blöde Idee ist, wenn man halt Pässe mit Unique Identifier benutzt. Weil jeder schön Bomben oder was auch immer bauen kann, die halt genau auf diese eine Unique Identifier explodieren. Oder halt gerade die Überwachung von Personen, die Verfolgung von Personen damit sehr einfach möglich ist.
Und deshalb also insbesondere auch in den USA gab es halt auch eine größere Kampagne, wo einfach gerade US-Bürger, die mit ihren funkenden Reisepässen durch die Welt reisen, nicht als rumrennende Opfer, quasi da als Ziel scheiden. Deshalb gab es in Amerika durchaus einen größeren Aufruhr als hier. Ihnen ist in letzter Sekunde aufgefallen, dass eine UID vielleicht keine gute Idee ist.
Aber wir haben sie.
Nee, was sie halt dann getan haben, genau ist, sie haben diese UID ausgetauscht durch eine randommäßig erzeugte UID. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen widersinnig. Aber auf jeden Fall, es ist halt keine UID mehr. Aber dieses Verfahren dient auch zur Antikollision, um festzustellen, welcher Chip wirklich angesprochen ist, oder dass nur einer angesprochen wird.
Das verstehe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz.
Also wenn jetzt dieser Chip an mir vorbeiläuft, ich bin ein Lesegerät, jetzt funke ich da einfach dran und sage irgendwie, hallo, sprich mit mir.
Genau, das Erste, was der Chip...
Was spuckt denn der unverschlüsselt raus?
Die UID.
Einfach sofort. Genau. Das tut er auch jetzt. Was heißt randomisiert? Das heißt, er spuckt jedes Mal eine andere aus?
Genau. Was soll das? Das dient genau dazu, dass nicht personenspezifisch für Bomben gebaut werden, wo das Leute...
Aber wozu braucht man die, wenn sie nicht eine ID ist?
Zur Antikollision. Also, wenn zwei Pässe in dem gleichen Feld sind, dass immer nur eine angesprochen wird.
Das heißt, es geht nur darum, dass man, wenn mehrere da sind, jeden einzelnen...
Die UID wurde ehemals zur Antikollision eingesetzt, dass halt genau mehrere Chips im gleichen Feld separat angesprochen werden können.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so fünf Pässe habe und ich sage hallo, dann kann es sein, dass ich fünfmal ja, hallo, hier bin ich, deinen Reisepass zurückbekomme. Kann ich dann an der Antwort selber auch jetzt schon sehen, dass es ein Reisepass ist?
Na, kann man halt sehen, weil dieses randomisierte UID halt normalerweise nicht verwendet wird. Also, es wird eigentlich soweit ich weiß...
Aber wobei man es denn eine randomisierte von einer nicht randomisierten...
Wenn du es zweimal abfragst. Oder mehrfach. Also, wenn halt mehrfach ist, dann gibt es entweder, du hast mehrere Pässe in Lese-Reichweite, oder es ist halt ein und derselbe Pass, der halt...
Wie häufig kann man so abfragen pro Sekunde?
Mehrfach zehnmal die Sekunde sollte auf jeden Fall gehen.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man da irgendwie...
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, also drei schafft man locker pro Sekunde.
Okay, also man kann schon unterscheiden zwischen, da meldet sich derselbe immer wieder mit einer anderen ID.
Also, gerade wenn man halt die Zeitstärke hat.
Ja, wenn man mal eine ganze Horde von Touristen gerade aus dem Bus rausgeströmt, kommt alle mit ihren Pässen in der Hand.
Na, kommt drauf an, wo die Horde her ist, denn wir reden jetzt immer nur über die deutsche Variante. Andere Länder haben sich...
Also, wenn man halt einfach eine hohe Zahl an Auslese vorgegeben macht, dann wird man es halt irgendwann feststellen. Also, man kann sagen, das sind halt keine 100 verschiedenen Pässe, wenn man halt 100 verschiedene URDs zurückkriegt. Das heißt, irgendwann kann man auf jeden Fall feststellen, dass es ein Chip ist, der random randomisierte URDs ausgibt. Und dann wiederum ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch, dass es sich um Reisepass handelt.
Und was muss man jetzt als nächstes tun, um mit diesem Chip reden zu können?
Genau. Als nächstes braucht man einen Key, einen Schlüssel. Also die Daten, die Kommunikation selber, ist verschlüsselt. Und der Schlüssel berechnet sich aus der machine-lesbaren Zone.
Also aus der Nummer?
Aus einem Teil der machine-lesbaren Zone. Genau. Wenn man sich jetzt mal den Pass vor Augen hält, dann hat man oben links in der Ecke sein Passbild. Und unten drunter sind zwei Zeilen mit ganz vielen kleiner Zeichen. Genau, da steht Erika Mustermann. Dahinter steht das Geburtsdatum, das Ablaufdatum und die Pass-ID. Und die Pass-ID, das Geburtsdatum und das Ablaufdatum sind zusammen der Schlüssel für die Kommunikation. Das heißt, eine Kommunikation an der Grenze jetzt, wo sie so vorgesehen ist, wenn man die Basic Access-Control verwendet. Aber da muss man das ja schon vorher wissen. Genau, die Maschinen-Disparation ist halt der Schlüssel für die Basic Access-Control.
Das heißt, man muss den Pass erstmal optisch lesen?
Richtig. Das wollte ich gerade genau. Also festzustellen, das ist wichtig. Ja, das Verfahren sieht so aus, dass man den Pass auf einen optischen Scanner legt, der genau einmal scannt, der die Maschinen-Insparationen per OCR ermittelt. Also diese drei Datenfelder ermittelt und daraus den Kommunikationsschlüssel für die Kommunikation mit dem Chip herstellt. Im nächsten Schritt wird dann das Passbild ausgelesen, also verschlüsselt übertragen. Wobei gesagt werden muss, dass der Schlüssel natürlich relativ geringe Entropie hat. Also ich meine, so Geburtsdatum ist halt relativ festgelegt. Das Ablaufdatum ist relativ festgelegt, wenn man ungefähr weiß, wann der Pass ausgestellt wurde oder also gerade jetzt von einem Neues hat er halt entweder zehn Jahre oder fünf Jahre.
Gültigkeit.
Gültigkeit, genau. Also das Ablaufdatum ist halt relativ eingeschränkt.
Langsam mit dem Pferd, nur um diesen Vorgang nochmal klarzumachen. Also es gibt eine Sicherung, die darauf beruht, dass man diesen Chip nur auslesen kann, wenn man einen selbst zusammensammelbaren Schlüssel hat. Und den kriegt man dadurch, dass man das Ding optisch liest. Mit einem Wort, man muss diesen Pass nehmen, durch irgendein Lesegerät durchziehen, dann werden die ganzen Größerzeichen entfernt. Und es bleibt Erika-Muss am Geborenen-Abend. Und was nicht noch alles da drauf steht. Und daraus kann sich dann ein Gerät diesen Schlüssel zusammenbauen. Das heißt, den kann auch jeder andere sich zusammenbauen. Wenn er diesen Pass physikalisch hat, das verhindert jetzt nicht, dass man ihn nicht lesen kann. Das verhindert nur, dass man ihn nicht lesen kann, wenn man ihn nicht vorher optisch gesehen hat.
Oder hat einmal einen Blick drauf geworfen.
Also man kann auch mal mit der Digitalkamera draufhalten, dann ist man in der Lage, ihn nochmal auszulesen.
Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, dass Kopien von Pässen relativ üblich sind. Also immer wenn du ein Hotelzimmer irgendwo haben willst, oder...
Das ist sogar sehr häufig in letzter Zeit. Manche Copy-Shops machen das. Oder wenn man ein Gerät in Reparatur gibt.
Copy-Shops.
Ja, ich habe das schon bei Copy-Shops erlebt. Oder ich habe es mal bei dem Rechner erlebt, wenn man den Rechner angestellt und so. Genau. Es ist gar nicht so selten, dass man eine Kopie von seinem Reisepass macht.
Okay, das heißt, man hat jetzt diesen ersten Key. Und wie du schon sagst, er hat geringe Entropie. Also darauf willst du jetzt anspielen, dass es unter Umständen möglich ist, da eine kryptographische Schwäche drin zu finden?
Also es sind erst mal 56 Bit. Wer sich halt ein bisschen mit Kryptographie auskennt, weiß, dass das halt nicht so wirklich viel ist.
Na, was ist denn für ein Algorithmus da im Einsatz?
Das ist Triple Desk. Der einzige Schutz...
Der einzige Schutz, ne?
Also die Sicherheit bei dem Pass ist halt, dass der Chip selber relativ langsam ist. Das heißt, man kann halt nur, sagen wir, fünf oder drei Anfragen an den Chip pro Sekunde stellen. Das heißt, um halt alle 56 Bit auszuprobieren, würde es halt schon mehrere hundert Jahre dauern. Und da kommt das, was ich halt vorne mal ansprechen wollte, mit dem passiven Abhören ins Spiel. Das heißt, man kann eine authentifizierte Kommunikation zwischen einem Lesegerät und einem Pass abhören. Das geht halt mit gutem Antennequipment über mehrere Meter wirklich. Also halt so bis zu 10, 20 Meter sind da drin. Was halt auch das BSI schon irgendwie nachgewiesen hat oder schon mal getestet hat.
Weil dagegen ist man ja nicht immun. Es wird einfach gefunkt. Das heißt, es ist einfach im Raum.
Genau. Und diese Kommunikation kann man natürlich abhören. Die ist initial verschlüsselt, aber halt nur mit 65 Bit, mit 56 Bit. Und wenn man genau diese verschlüsselte Daten auf dem Rechner, dann versucht, zu brute force, also halt mit allen möglichen Varianten, die es da gibt. Also halt irgendwie Geburtsdatum sind halt in der Regel so 100 mal 356 Tage, also irgendwie 300.000 Möglichkeiten, 30.000 Möglichkeiten. Ablaufdatum 10 Jahre mal 356 Tage, wobei da auch wieder Einschränkungen sind mit Wochenende und was auch immer. Also die eigentliche wirkliche Entropie ist die Pass-ID. Die ist zehn Zeichen lang und die ist numerisch.
Für die, die es nicht wissen, Entropie ist so die Kennzahl für die Menge des Chaos. Man kann manchmal nicht genug davon haben, insbesondere wenn es um Kryptografie geht. Was ich jetzt noch nicht ganz verstanden habe, ist, du hast gesagt, die Kommunikation ist initial verschlüsselt. Das heißt, beginnt das bereits mit diesem Basic Access-Control? Also das ist sozusagen der Anfang. Also das Einzige, was wirklich unverschlüsselt ist, ist die… Wenn man eine Fotokopie hat, dann kann man die auf jeden Fall schon mal komplett mithören. Und dann, was passiert dann als nächstes?
Na, das ist dann schon alles.
Man hat diesen Key und dann wird einfach geantwortet. Hallo, ich bin, mein Name ist…
Wenn du die Kopie hast, oder es reicht, wenn du die Maschinenlesbare Zone hast, dann hast du ja die Daten…
Sowieso schon.
Genau. Der zweite, was Starbug jetzt erwähnte, war einfach die Möglichkeit, sich daneben zu stellen und einfach mitzulauschen, wie jemand diesen Pass ausliest. Etwa ein offizielles Lesegerät in der Grenze, wo ja zum Beispiel der Reisender seinen Pass ohnehin auflegt. Also sind ja zwei verschiedene Felder, die da unterscheiden.
Also wo man halt keine Offline-Kopie, also keine Analog-Kopie des Passes hat und halt den Schlüssel nicht hat.
Sondern einfach daneben steht, eine Antenne hinhält und dann ja die Daten auf dem Rechner hat und mit einer anderen Rechenpower daran gehen kann, diese Kopiografie zu brechen und eben da die Merkmale zu benutzen, die eben gerade diese Nummer hat, nämlich dass man Teile davon raten kann oder zumindest sinnvoll Teile ausschließen kann.
Das ist einfach der Schutz, dass der Chip selber nur eine geringe Performance hat, ist halt da ausgehebelt, weil man halt die Software, also den Algorithmus in schneller Software implementieren kann auf dem Rechner oder auf mehreren Rechnern und da dann halt im Endeffekt den schwachen Schlüssel in wenigen Stunden auf jeden Fall probforcen kann, also alle Möglichkeiten ausprobieren kann.
Das ist auch nicht nur in Deutschland gezeigt worden, wir hatten ja als erstes die Rollen da.
Aber das funktioniert dann nur mit einem Pass?
Das muss man für jeden Pass separat machen, ja.
Das heißt, das Bedrohungsszenario klingt natürlich jetzt erst mal nicht besonders groß, so nach dem Motto, er will Kandidaten nur dann auslesen, wenn er sie eh schon als Fotokopie vorliegen hat, dann müsste er sie ja auch nicht auslesen, aber es geht jetzt eigentlich eher um diesen Vorgang als solchen, dass man den mitlauschen kann.
Also was man dann hat am Endeffekt an Daten, sind halt wieder die Maschinen-Instrumentationen, also den Schlüssel und das Passbild in digitaler Qualität.
Das heißt, mehr als nur zu sehen ist auf dem Passbild.
Na okay, man kriegt auch noch das Foto.
Und zwar in eben genau der Qualität verwirrt die Variation.
Na gut, das Foto ist ja auch zu sehen, aber man kriegt es halt nicht so schön digitalisiert.
Man kriegt es halt bitidentisch, also halt in guter Qualität, in biometrisch verwertbarer Qualität und halt immer identisch. Also man kriegt dann immer den gleichen bitstrumenten-Instrumenten. Das heißt, man kann damit wieder Personen dann tracken.
Okay, das heißt, dass der Pass elektronisch ist, wird eigentlich erst dadurch wirklich zum Problem, weil man jetzt auch noch die biometrischen Daten quasi mitgeliefert bekommt und die potenziell auch für Dritte auslesbar sind. Beziehungsweise ist es ja eigentlich auslesbar. Wer soll denn das auslesen? Es geht ja nicht nur um deutsche Behörden, es geht ja auch um die USA, wenn ich da hinfahre, überall. Das heißt, man liefert jetzt sozusagen so jetzt keine Ahnung. Also es gibt ja viel Tourismus nach, was weiß ich, Israel.
Man sagt ja mal, die Deutschen sind Ex-Reiseweltmeister.
So, das heißt, diese vollständigen Informationen, die da drauf sind, einschließlich des voll digitalisierten Fotos, schön biometrietauglich, liegt dann auch überall vor, kann komplett ausgelesen werden.
Also wirklich überall in allen Ländern, wo man halt hinweist, ist ein Standard.
Außerhalb von Schengen. Jetzt sollte man vielleicht auch mal erwähnen, auch das biometrische Gesichtsbild ist weltweit standardisiert mittlerweile. Mittlerweile ist es auch eine ISO, die hat die Nummer 199745. Also auch hier haben wir eine Standardisierung, damit man auch möglichst Interoperabilität herstellen kann. Also es ist nicht nur der Chip, sondern auch das Bild an sich.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man diese Daten hat, dann kann man im Prinzip genauso gut Bild erkennen, wie der Staat dann auch kann. Und kann irgendwo eine Kamera hinstellen und mal draufhalten und mal gucken, wer so vorbeikommt.
Wir kommen jetzt halt in eine neue Problematik dadurch. Dadurch, dass in ganz Europa diese biometrischen Reisepässe ausgegeben werden, heißt es erstmal nur schlicht, dass die viel reisenden Europäer diese biometrischen Daten quasi zwangsweise in aller Welt verteilen. Und zwar mit jeder Reise und mit jedem Jahr mehr. Denn jetzt wird ja sukzessive immer, also jedes Jahr mehr, von diesen Reisepassen ausgegeben. Und entsprechend wird sich mit jedem Jahr die Anzahl derjenigen, die sich mit diesen biometrischen Daten durch die Welt bewegt, erhöhen. Und hinzu kommt halt die Entwicklung, die wir parallel sehen. Nicht nur in Europa, sondern auch global. Nämlich, dass die Biometrieindustrie insgesamt auf dem Vormarsch ist. Prognostiziert sind weltweit Milliardenmärkte. Es gibt schon sehr viele Studien dazu, welche Umsätze zu erwarten sind. Weil eben auch in allgemeiner Konsumententechnik, etwa Handys und biometrische Sensoren, nach und nach Einzug nehmen. Wir haben ja sogar schon den Aldi-Computer, der einen biometrischen Sensor hat. Mittlerweile in Berlin gibt es jetzt einige Videotheken, die anfangen damit. Ja, aber es gibt auch schon Gesichtsbilder. Es hat so beides.
Es gibt Videotheken mit Gesichtsbilderkennung?
Videotheken noch nicht. Aber es gibt ja durchaus Länder, die diese kontaktbehaftete Verfahren, weil beim Fingerabdrucken muss man ja anfassen, nicht so schön finden. Es gibt ja so, also gerade im asiatischen Raum ist das nicht so sehr beliebt. Da wird dann eher auf Gesichtsbild oder auf Iriden eben ausgewichelt.
Also wo zum Beispiel Gesichtsbild in Deutschland eingesetzt wird, ist Hannover an der Zoo. Da wird halt die Dauerkartenbesitzer mit Biometrie mit Gesichtsbild reingelassen. Also es gibt halt tatsächlich schon Anwendungen, die sind halt noch relativ gering. Aber auf jeden Fall. Na, ihre Begründung war gewesen, dass normalerweise die Dauerkarten halt weitergegeben wurden und sie wollten halt damit eine eindeutige Zuordnung von Dauerkartenbesitzern zu Leuten, die halt reinkommen.
Haben sie ein großes Missbrauchsproblem gehabt?
Haben sie zumindest so gesagt, ja.
Haben sich die Elefanten sozusagen auf Stammgäste gefreut und dann kamen irgendwelche Asylbewerber oder so. Haben wir denn jetzt sozusagen die elektronische Komponente des Passes, so wie er heute existiert, jetzt schon vollständig beschrieben?
Eigentlich schon. Das ist vielleicht höchstens noch die Problematik mit dem Klon dieser Chips, die wir jetzt noch nicht angesprochen haben. Und natürlich auch noch die Problematik, wie es anders sein wird, wenn die Fingerabdrücke kommen, weil sich ja was ändert.
Vielleicht mal das Klon, das ist ganz interessant. Das war ja auch noch mal so ein kleines Medienereignis vor ein paar Monaten, dass irgendjemand das dann gezeigt hat, dass das geht. War das jetzt so überraschend?
Eigentlich nicht. Zumindest in Deutschland hat es halt jeder gewusst. Und auch irgendwie die ganzen offiziellen Stellen, die halt angefragt wurden, und sagen, ja, das war uns klar, wir haben da keine Schutzmaßnahmen dagegen vorgesehen, weil das brauchen wir nicht. Aber halt die Bürger, also es zeigt halt auch, wie uninformiert die Presse und die Bürger waren. Also da hat es schon einen relativ großen Aufruf gegeben, weil man halt da einmal gesehen hat, wie doch leichtsinnig mit den Daten umgegangen wird. Also ich meine, im Endeffekt ist es halt nicht wirklich schlimm, den Klon zu können, weil man halt...
Na, man kann sich... Was bedeutet das? Man kann sich genau so ein Chip nehmen, das ist ja ein Standard, den kann man sich wahrscheinlich einfach im Katalog bestellen. Der Algorithmus ist irgendwie klar, man muss ihn jetzt noch selber programmieren, oder was muss man tun?
Zum Beispiel, ja. Also was halt Klon in dem Fall heißt, dass man halt wirklich die Daten eins zu eins kopieren kann. Das heißt, man kann halt einen Chip oder einen Pass herstellen, der dann halt aber das Bild, das Originalbild und die Originaldaten von jemand anderem hat. Also man kann die Daten nicht verändern. Und deswegen haben auch die deutschen Behörden gesagt, gegen Klon, also es gäbe halt Möglichkeiten, das Klon zu verhindern, gegen Klon machen wir nichts, weil wir das nicht als Gefahr sehen.
Denn den Reisepass, den wir haben, also das physische Dokument, ist ein hochsicheres Dokument, und man muss sagen, das ist eigentlich Beispielgebend für die ganze Welt. Das heißt, wir haben auch im internationalen Vergleich, jetzt wenn man die physischen Sicherheitsmerkmale, wie die Hologramme, die Drucktechnik und auch viele Merkmale, es sind so 15, 17 Merkmale, die dort zusammenfallen, auf diesem Dokument, die sind halt hochsicher. Entsprechend müsste man ja, wenn man den Chip-Klon, kommen wir gleich zu, wenn man den Chip-Klon, braucht man ja eigentlich auch ein identisches Dokument, um die Fälschung komplett zu machen. Und hier ist ja die Problematik, denn wir wissen, auch aus offiziellen Antworten der Bundesregierung, dass es keine guten Fälschungen gibt.
Das sagt man zahlend.
Ja, wir wissen, das waren sechs innerhalb von fünf Jahren. Also in den Jahren 2001 bis 2006 sind halt de facto nur sechs Totalfälschungen bekannt geworden. Also keine de facto.
Genau, und die Begründung, warum sie halt ehemals, oder eine Mitbegründung, warum sie den Elektronischen Reisepass eingeführt haben, hieß natürlich, weil wir die Sicherheit erhöhen wollen. Was man halt auf der Seite sieht, also die Kosten für die Einführung sind auf jeden Fall im mindestens dreistelligen Millionenbereich, also mindestens plus halt jährliche Kosten, die halt mindestens nochmal dreistelligen Millionenbereich sind.
Also insgesamt sind wir auf jeden Fall bei einer Milliarde.
Und das heißt, für sechs Fälschungen in fünf Jahren haben sie halt eine Milliarde Euro aus Haushaltsmitteln oder aus Steuermitteln oder halt direkt von den Leuten abgegriffen. Weil natürlich der Pass selber...
Damit die Asylbewerber sich nicht mit einem EU-Pass reinsprungeln können.
Oder dass die bösen Terroristen bei uns keine Anschläge mehr durchführen können.
Also es ist auch so, dass da kommt eigentlich noch ein Aspekt hinzu. Denn in derselben Antwort, wo wir erfahren haben, wie viele eigentlich zahlenmäßig Fälschungen es gibt, war auch noch eine weitere Frage, nämlich die, ob denn irgendwelche von diesen Fälschungen, was mit terroristischen Anschlägen zu tun gehabt hätten, also ob es eine Problematik gibt, dass Fälschung oder Verfälschung bei Pässen in Bezug auf terroristische Planung eine Rolle spielt. Und die Antwort war nein. Das war nicht angegeben. Die Antwort war nur, es gab keinen Zusammenhang mit terroristischen Planungen.
Das heißt, alle ihre Angaben, warum sie den in den biometrischen Pass einführen wollen, sind halt hinfällig gewesen. Genau in dieser Antwort wurde gesagt, dass es weder große, signifikante Anzahl von Verfälschungen gab oder Fälschungen gab, noch dass sie irgendwie was mit terroristischen Anschlägen zu tun haben. Genau die beiden Argumente sind weggefahren.
Das heißt, man kann vermuten, dass der eigentliche Druck, das jetzt so einzuführen, andere Gründe hat?
Wirtschaftspolitisch.
Das war ja auch genau mal die Antwort aus dem Innenministerium, dass es durchaus auch wirtschaftspolitische Aspekte hat. Man sollte das vielleicht nicht verurteilen. Es ist ein legitimes Ziel unserer Bundesregierung, unsere Wirtschaft zu fördern. Die Frage ist nur, welchen Preis zahlen die Bürger dafür? Und ist dies gerechtfertigt? Und wie können wir jetzt auch schon einen Blick darauf werfen, ob diese Strategie Erfolg gehabt hat? Hat denn tatsächlich mit diesem Riesenreferenzprojekt die deutsche Biometrieindustrie am Ende profitiert? Der Sinn war ja, möglichst frühzeitig dieses große Projekt anzuleiern, damit die herstellenden Firmen eine Chance haben, diese Technologie in Bezug auf RFID, aber auch in Bezug auf Biometrie in aller Welt verkaufen zu können. Und da kann man sich jetzt schon mal fragen, ob es Erfolg hat. Und die Antwort muss eigentlich lauten eher nicht. Denn mit der Ausnahme von Cognitech, die in einigen Ländern, also Cognitech GmbH, die in Deutschland für die Gesichtserkennung die Geräte liefert, außer dieser Firma muss man sagen, dass die ganzen nationalen Länder natürlich ihre eigene Industrie unterstützt haben. Und da kaum diese großen Effekte zu erwarten sind. Der einzige zu erwartende Effekt ist halt der Gewöhnungseffekt bei der Bevölkerung.
Das heißt, diese Technik, die jetzt hier in Deutschland entwickelt wurde, um diesen elektronischen Pass möglich zu machen, bzw. ihn später auch nutzbar zu machen, Bilderkennung usw., die wird eigentlich auch nur im Wesentlichen in Deutschland eingesetzt, noch nicht mal EU-weit. Das heißt, die Spanier haben irgendwie ihre eigenen Firmen am Start usw.
Es gibt natürlich immer kleine Länder, die das irgendwie mal getestet haben, von Deutschen, aber es ist halt kein Export-Schlager, wie es halt immer so schön heißt, geworden.
Bevor ich das noch vergesse, was ich eben noch wissen wollte, also diese physikalischen Merkmale, werden die denn auch geprüft an der Grenze? Also ich meine, werden die auch automatisiert geprüft, wird das Hologramm irgendwie gescannt, wird irgendwie das Papier?
Ja, sie haben verschiedene Techniken. Also zunächst mal sind in der Regel diese Grenzbeamten sehr gut geschult. Das heißt, welche und wie diese Merkmale im Einzelnen aussehen, wissen die sehr gut. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch Möglichkeiten mit Licht, also bestimmte Arten von Licht, besondere von den Merkmalen zu testen.
Also es gibt halt einfach Infrarot-Druckfarbe, die halt auf Infrarotlicht oder auf UV-Licht reagiert. Das heißt, wenn der Pass dann mal gescannt wird, dann wird halt auch explizit geguckt, ob diese Merkmale an der Stelle sind und irgendwie auf das Licht reagiert haben.
Das ist also dieses Apparat, wo dann irgendwie wieder zurückfliegt, das Ding einmal kurz reingesteckt wird.
Also hier ist wirklich eine Menge Know-How in diesem Pass geflossen. Das ist ohne Frage.
Also schon vorher, bevor der halt biometrisch oder mit dem Chip aufgerüstet wurde.
Also man muss schon sehen, dass auch die Art, wie der hergestellt wird, also die technischen Verfahren einfach anspruchsvoll sind, sodass Fälscher damit Probleme haben.
Also so was wie Komplettfälschung sind halt eigentlich relativ ausgeschlossen bei deutschen Passen. Also es gibt halt so Fährfälschungen, wo halt irgendwie das Passbild raus repariert wird und versucht wird, ein neues Passbild reinzumachen. Aber die sind halt in den meisten Fällen so stümperhaft, dass sie halt relativ schnell auffallen. Also wo halt auch ohne zusätzliche Sicherheitsmerkmal einfach irgendwie jeder Grenzer, weil wahrscheinlich sogar jeder Polizist gesehen hätte, dass es einfach eine Verfälschung ist.
Es kommt halt auch noch dazu, dass man sagen muss, dass die Qualität der einzelnen Pässe in Deutschland recht hoch ist. Denn wenn sich so eine Varianz bei der Herstellung ergibt, dann ist auch klar, dass man als Fälscher auch Möglichkeiten hat, wenn man immer sagen kann, ja, den habe ich so bekommen. Aber bei uns sind die halt auch in einem einzelnen Stück von hoher Qualität. Das macht die Verfälschung ja nochmal schwieriger.
So, jetzt, 1. November 2005 hatten wir die Einführung der Gesichtsbiometrie in den Pass. Jetzt, 1. November 2007. Also jetzt gibt es Teil 2 und jetzt kommen die Fingerabdrücke dazu. Was verändert sich denn jetzt technisch an dem Pass konkret?
Der Pass selber ist identisch mit dem vorherigen, außer dass halt ein zusätzlicher bzw. 2 zusätzliche Felder beschrieben wurden, wo halt jetzt die Bilder, also wieder JPEG 2000 komprimierte Bilder von Fingerabdrücken auf dem Pass drauf sind.
Diesmal 18k.
Genau, diesmal 18k. Und zusätzlich noch kryptographische Schlüssel, um diese Fingerabdrücke zusätzlich zu sichern.
Das heißt, die sind nicht so ohne weiteres auslesbar, wenn man jetzt diesen Basic Access Kontrol hat. Das Bild ist aber nicht so gesichert nach wie vor.
Nein, das Bild bleibt halt, wie es ist.
Basic Access Kontrol gesichert, also mit dieser Verfahren, aus der Form beschrieben, mit der Maschinen-Expansone. Jetzt zusätzlich die Fingerabdrücke.
Das war keine Diskussion, das Bild vielleicht auch noch mal zu verschlüsseln?
Nee, weil es gibt, also der Basic Access Kontrol ist halt ein fester Standard. Also wenn sie das jetzt noch mal zusätzlich umgeworfen hätten, hätten sie irgendwie alles anders machen müssen. Und vor allem, weil halt die Extended Access Kontrol, also diese zusätzliche Sicherung für die Fingerabdrücke, natürlich technisch deutlich anspruchsvoller ist.
Also die offizielle Begründung sieht natürlich anders aus. Die offizielle Begründung lautet, dass die Fingerabdruckdaten deutlich sensitiver sind. Und das ist deshalb ein erhöhtes Sicherheitsniveau. Natürlich sagen die Offiziere nicht, wir könnten ja diesen Standard jetzt auch nicht nochmal kippen und das für alle sicherer machen. Offiziere sagen sie natürlich, dass die Fingerabdrücke viel sensibler sind.
Und warum sind sie viel sensibler?
Naja, sind sie es?
Man lässt sich das jetzt irgendwie, wenn man da mit Biometrietechnologie draufschaut.
Sind sie schon. Also wo halt Gesicht... Ich versuche das mal zu auszuführen. Also wo halt ein Gesicht eigentlich gar nicht zur Identifizierung von Personen herangenommen werden kann, weil halt einfach die Erkennungsraten so schlecht sind. Es ist bei Fingerabdrücken natürlich schon ein bisschen anders. Also da hat man halt schon so Erkennungsraten, die halt so um die 90, 95 Prozent liegen. Also halt schon höher, aber halt für Passanwendung immer noch deutlich zu niedrig. Also man hat immer noch Fehlerraten von, lass es nur 2 Prozent sein, was halt aber einfach mal, wenn man sich die Bevölkerungszahl daneben vergleichen anguckt, mit 340 Millionen Europäern, dann sind halt 2 Prozent immer noch Millionen, die dann halt irgendwie eventuell falsch erkannt wurden.
Ja, oder wenn ich 2 Prozent mal hochrechne auf so den täglichen Durchgang bei großen Airports, wie in Frankfurt, das sind ja dann irgendwie Tausende.
Das ist sehr unangenehm, klar, deshalb sagen ja auch gerade die großen Fluggesellschaften, na ach, meine Güte, was kommt da auf uns zu?
Warum ist das so? Also warum kann ein Fingerabdruck so schlecht erkannt werden?
Okay, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Varianten. Also erstmal prinzipiell diese 2 bis 5 Prozent, die wir gerade angesprochen haben, betrifft Finger, die keine ausreichend ausgeprägten Merkmale haben. Als Fingerabdruck wird hier die Minuzia bezeichnet, also die Hautfaltungen, die halt als Identifizierung angenommen werden. Und es gibt halt gewisse Bevölkerungsgruppen, die halt keine ausreichend ausgeprägten Merkmale haben. Das sind vor allem Kinder, wo halt das einfach noch nicht so weit entwickelt ist. Es sind vor allem asiatische Frauen.
Die haben keine Linien?
Die sind halt noch sehr dünn. Oder halt sehr feucht, sehr fettig, sehr trocken, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, wo die Aufnahmegeräte, die Sensoren Schwierigkeiten haben, das Fingerabdruckbild aufzunehmen. Also es betrifft einmal Kinder und es betrifft vor allem halt auch ältere Leute. Also halt Senioren, die halt wieder, wenn man sich betrachtet, halt viele Reiser sind. Das heißt, irgendwie ist die Personengruppe, die nachher halt gehäuft an der Grenze stehen wird. Und die ist halt auch die Gruppe, die halt große Probleme hat. Also da sind wir halt wirklich schon fast im zweistelligen Prozentbereich, wo halt alte Leute keine Fingerabdrücke zum Beispiel haben.
Es gibt sogar, also wir kennen jetzt auch schon praktische Forschungen, die über diese von jetzt eben Starbug erwähnten typischen Werte, die bei den internationalen Studien so rauskommen, zwischen irgendwie so zwei, drei Prozent in der Regel immer, weit hinausgehen. Also auf dem letzten Biosig 2004, da gab es einen Vortrag. Das ist ein Workshop, der, ich glaube, erst zweimal...
Das ist vom BSI ausgetragen, ein Workshop, der sich halt speziell mit Biometrien anbindet und beschäftigt.
Und da war mal von praktischen Untersuchungen die Rede, und da war von elf Prozent die Rede, und zwar von Erwachsenen, die dermatologische Krankheitsbilder zeigen würden. Wenn man also mal Studien nimmt, die aus dem medizinischen Bereich kommen, die also gar nichts mit der Biometrieindustrie zu tun haben eigentlich, kommt man auf ganz andere Zahlen. Denn wir haben in vielen von diesen Biometriestudien gesehen, dass die ausgewählten Teilnehmer, also die Probanden, gar nicht repräsentativ sind. Denn wir haben ja gerade in Europa eine sehr stark alternde Bevölkerung, also über alle Länder hinweg gesehen, besonders aber auch in Deutschland. Und wenn man sich medizinische Studien ansieht, dann sind die deutlich höher, weil die sind bereits im zweistelligen Prozentbereich.
Also wo auch ganz klar den Durchführern dieser Studien irgendwie Vorwürfe gemacht werden müssen, dass sie gezielt falsche Personengruppen ausgewählt haben oder nicht repräsentative Personengruppen ausgesucht haben, um die Ergebnisse im Endeffekt zu schönen. Also um zu sagen, wir haben da eigentlich wenig Probleme, wobei irgendwie zwei Prozent sind nicht wenig Probleme, aber die Zahl liegt im Endeffekt halt noch wirklich deutlich höher.
Wir können die Zahlen, die ermittelt wurden für den größten deutschen Feldtest, die sogenannte BiOP-2-Studie, wir können die eigentlich gar nicht ernst nehmen, die sind schon schlimm. Aber dadurch, dass etwa, also gebe ich nun mal ein Beispiel für die BiOP-2-Studie, wir hatten da so Zahlen wie 70 Prozent der Probanden waren arbeitende Männer. Entsprechend also waren die Problemgruppen, wie etwa Senioren, nur mit einem Prozent vertreten, aber in Wirklichkeit ist das halt ein Drittel einer Bundesrepublik. Und auch die Frauen, die signifikant schlechtere Erkennungswerte zeigen, waren eben nur zu 30 Prozent vertreten.
BiOP-2-Studie, musst du noch mal kurz erklären, ist was gewesen?
Sie hatten halt mehrere Feldtests gemacht.
Wer ist sie?
Also BMI hat es einem Auftrag gegeben und durchgeführt, hat es das BSI und hier der Lieblingsdienstleister.
BMI ist Bundesministerium des Inneren, BSI ist das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Und die wiederum hat so einen Dienstleister, den sie am liebsten nimmt, die ist die Firma Seekunet und die hat hier diesen Test ausgeführt. Es gab mehrere und der größte war auch der letzte in dem Bereich, diese BiOP-2-Studie.
Das ist jetzt wie lange her?
Ja genau, da hat aber dann im Juli 2005 von damaligen Innenminister Otto Schili dieses große Projekt und der Start des Projekts verkündet worden, waren die Ergebnisse noch gar nicht offiziell.
Also der Start des Reisepasses.
Genau, des Reisepasses. Aber wir haben später erst die Ergebnisse erfahren, da war aber die Entscheidung natürlich schon längst verkündet.
Also man muss sich das mal vorstellen, also wirklich mal den zeitlichen Ablauf. Da gibt die Bundesregierung einen Studienauftrag, um halt explizit die Technik für den neuen Reisepass zu evaluieren. Und als sie schon selber die Ergebnisse hatten, aber sie noch nicht öffentlich wurden, haben sie halt ganz schnell das Gesetz durchgepeitscht und irgendwie ein paar Wochen später, also die Veröffentlichung dieser Ergebnisse, ist halt immer wieder rausgeschoben worden. Und halt ein paar Wochen nach der offiziell bekannt, oder nach dem Abschluss des Gesetzes, ist dann halt die Ergebnisse bekannt geworden. Und die waren halt wirklich signifant schlecht. Also wenn man sie vorher gekannt hätte, hätte man eigentlich aus logischen Konsequenzen sagen müssen, wir können dieses Projekt IPASS eigentlich so nicht durchführen.
Das ging vor allen Dingen gar nicht mal nur um die Technik. Die Technik haben sie, also das heißt die Erkennungsraten, die Falschrückweisungsraten, wie viele Leute können tatsächlich erst erfasst werden, also solche Fragen. Aber es ging auch noch gleichzeitig um die Benutzbarkeit. Das heißt, die Probanden wurden auch noch befragt, wie sie denn überhaupt diese Geräte benutzen können, ob es vielleicht sehr große Schwächen gäbe in der Benutzerführung. Und auch die haben sich noch gezeigt. Also neben den technischen Schwächen der Algorithmen und auch der Sensorik, auch da haben sich Schwächen gezeigt, war auch noch die Benutzbarkeit nicht gegeben. Etwa zum Beispiel, wir nehmen wieder Rollstuhlfahrer. War halt nicht vorgesehen. Die konnten sich etwa vor dem Irrserkennungssystem nicht platzieren. War nicht vorgesehen.
Und auch die Akzeptanz. Also wo halt einfach Leute gesagt haben, wir wollen eigentlich unsere biometrischen Merkmale dort nicht abgeben, was halt auch in Deutschland nachher einen gewissen Prozentsatz der Bevölkerung einfach betreffen wird. Diese Fragen wurden natürlich auch dort eräutert.
Das heißt, diese Studie hat auch jetzt nicht nur Gesichtserkennung zum Thema gehabt?
Nein, Gesicht, Finger, Irriden. Also Augen-Iris-Erkennung. Sie hatten halt aus Gründen, die die Studie nicht konkret klar macht, überhaupt nur vier Systeme getestet. Aufgrund welcher Kriterien? Also vier Hersteller-Systeme? Zwei Fingerabdruck, ein Gesicht, eine Iris. Zu den Kriterien wird eigentlich in der Studie nur eine Bemerkung gemacht. Diese Bemerkung ist, es war eine Marktsichtung. Was tatsächlich dazu geführt hat, dass diese Hersteller genommen wurden und andere nicht, bleibt vollkommen unklar. Es gibt dann noch eine nebulöse Bemerkung, wie in den früheren kleineren Tests seien die ja Testsieger gewesen. Was uns natürlich zum Lachen gebracht hat, weil wir ja auch schon die Ergebnisse der kleineren Tests davor kannten. Man muss sagen, die peinlichen Ergebnisse, die dürren Ergebnisse, die in den kleineren Tests davor rauskamen, die dann später in der Biop-2-Studie als Testsieger hinzustellen, fanden wir natürlich schon sehr lustig. Also hier ist natürlich auch eine gewisse, wie soll ich das mal nennen? Das ist eine gewisse incestuöse, immer wieder dieselben Firmen.
Da schließt sich auf jeden Fall Kreis wieder, wo man halt sieht, deutsche Biometriefirmen, die halt explizit dort den Aufträge zugeschachert worden sein sollen. Vielleicht noch ein kurzer Hinweis auf die Datenscheuder 91, die sich explizit auch mit dem E-Pass beschäftigt, ist jetzt inzwischen auch schon wieder ein Jahr alt oder sogar schon öfter, länger. Stimmt, 2005 war das auch. Wo halt auch nochmal diese Biop2-Studie nochmal sehr ausführlich und sehr schön mal auseinandergenommen wurde, mit den ganzen Fakten. Einfach, wenn die mal jemand lesen will auf Datenscheuder 91.
Ja, gibt's auch online als... Ja, gibt's auch auf Chaosradio. Ein Datenscheuder-PDF-Podcast.
Auch so was ist ein bisschen Chaosradio-Podcast. Also, Starbug und ich, wir haben dazu auch schon mal veröffentlicht. Wir haben die Studie sozusagen auch schon mal schriftlich gemacht. Und das kann man auch im Netz abrufen. Nämlich ist diese FIF-Kommunikationsheft, und zwar 4.2005. Da haben wir noch mal ein paar Seiten, wo wir die expliziten Ergebnisse aus diesen, das waren 200 Seiten, die BOP-2-Stunde, ja, etwa, ja. Also, wo wir die mal zusammenfassen auf ein paar Seiten.
Also, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr lesenswert, weil hat man einfach mal...
Ist online heißt, die Links finden sich dann hier auch in der MP3-Datei, die diese Aufzeichnung generiert, natürlich wieder. Wenn es funktioniert. Wenn es funktioniert, aber bisher hat es eigentlich immer ganz gut funktioniert. Ich packe ja sowas immer gleich in die Lyrics, damit es gar nicht verloren geht.
Du bist ein Spezialexperte.
Ein Fuchs. Aber es steht natürlich auch auf der Webseite unter ChaosradioCCCD für diese Sendung, CRE 047. Soll ich mal eine kurze Club-Mate-Pause machen? Dann spielen wir jetzt bis auf weiteres leise Musik. Ja, Chaosradio Express 47, die kurze Pause ist schon vorbei und wir haben unsere vertrockneten Kälsen mit herrlicher Club-Mate genässt. Wir machen hier Werbe-Breaks, oder wie?
Nur für Marte und die Bundesdruckerei.
Ja, jetzt sind wir schon wieder ganz gut in Rage gekommen über viele Dinge. Ich wollte noch mal kurz eine Klammer schließen. Wir hatten ja jetzt festgehalten, diesen November kommt eine neue technische Eigenschaft in den Pass mit rein. Der Fingerabdruck wird gespeichert. Du hast gesagt, er wird verschlüsselt abgelegt. Wie wird er denn verschlüsselt und wer hat dafür den Schlüssel?
Also er wird nicht verschlüsselt abgelegt, er wird verschlüsselt übertragen. Also man kann ihn halt nur, also er ist offiziell, er ist ja unverschlüsselt auf dem Chip. Man kann ihn aber halt nur über den Übertragungsweg auslesen. Das heißt, er wird halt verschlüsselt übertragen. Also man kann ihn niemals unverschlüsselt aus dem Chip rausholen. Ja, aber das ist eine Feinheit.
Ja, aber das ist doch eine Verschlüsselung, die dann auch für die Bilder gilt.
Ja, aber die Bilder sind selber unverschlüsselt auf dem Chip gespeichert. Und das spielt keine Rolle, weil man sie nicht auslesen kann auf anderen Wege.
Dann verstehe ich den Unterschied nicht so richtig. Gibt es einen?
Ja.
Dann erklär nochmal. Also der Fingerabdruck?
Der Fingerabdruck, es gibt Bilder vom Fingerabdruck, die halt unverschlüsselt, die halt in JPEG 2000 komprimiert, auf dem Chip gespeichert sind.
Wie das Foto auch.
Genau, unverschlüsselt. Aber man kann sie halt nur über den verschlüsselten Kommunikationen aus dem Chip auslesen.
Okay. Und was ist an dieser verschlüsselten Kommunikation anders als an der normalen Basic Access-Kontrolle?
Das ist ein komplett anderes Verfahren. Also wo die Basic Access-Kontrolle halt auf Schlüsseln basiert, die halt auf dem Chip selber oder auf dem Pass selber aufgedruckt sind.
Okay, das hatten wir ja schon, in der Maschinenlesbaren Zone.
Genau, ist die... Wir sollten das die Amis mal aussprechen lassen.
Ja, das ist das, wo wir gerade sind. Also wir befinden uns alle mittlerweile. Also ihr Hörer seid gemeint. Wir befinden uns alle jetzt in der Maschinenlesbaren Zone.
Man muss sich da keinen Zungenbrech erlauben. Man kann auch einfach sagen, M-R-Z. M-L-Z.
Maschinen-Readable-Zone. Das klingt schöner, aber M-L-Z klingt so ein bisschen wie so eine Linkspartei. Egal, lassen wir das. Okay, also das ist diese Extended Access...
Extended Access Control schützt explizit die Fingerabdruckdaten oder halt andere biometrische Daten, die vielleicht in der Zukunft noch mal, also nach dem November aufgebracht werden. Also da ist zum Beispiel die Iris auch im Gespräch.
Okay, das heißt, das ist alles schon vorbereitet...
Das ist alles schon vorbereitet...
.und noch aufzuladen mit weiteren Sachen.
Aber nur für die Sicherheit. Also Fingerabdrücke sind in der Datengruppe 3 gespeichert, die Iris-Bilder Datengruppe 4 und wir haben noch bis zur Datengruppe 14 alles weitere offen. Das heißt, da ist noch ein bisschen Platz.
Man muss sich überlegen, es gibt ja sehr viele biometrische Merkmale beim Menschen. Man könnte etwa sein Gang sehr individuell oder wir nehmen seinen Herzschlag, der ist sehr individuell, sein Ohrvolumen. Das Ohrvolumen? Ja, Ohrvolumen. Du kennst mal so einen Ohrvolumentest, durchgeführt. Ja, das ist halt auch sehr individuell.
Wie wird das gemessen in Millilitern?
Ach, na praktisch lief es eigentlich so, dass sie werfen dir Schallwellen ins Ohr, in diesem Fall mittels eines Handys.
Weißes Rauschen, also halt alle Frequenzen gleich verteilt?
Genau, du merkst es aber nicht, weil du kriegst eine Musik, die du hörst. Und in diesem Handy war gleichzeitig auch ein Sensor, der die zurückempfängt und darüber wurde das Volumen des Ohrkanals berechnet. Dieses Merkmal ist sehr individuell. Nicht etwa, dass du denselben Ohrkanal hättest wie ich.
Also es ist nicht das Volumen, sondern es ist die Rückstreuung der verschiedenen Frequenzen.
Ah, okay, das heißt die Halleigenschaft sozusagen.
Also einfach mal so eine Idee, wo Leute auf Ideen kommen, was man irgendwie alles noch verwenden kann.
Oder eben ein einzelner Herzschlag ist so individuell. Diese Idee hatten wir auch noch. Es gibt dann noch diese Handwehen oder natürlich die ganze Hand.
Okay, du bringst mich von dem Fingerabdruck her. Mich interessiert nochmal, wie funktioniert diese Verschlüsselung? Also was ist an der jetzt, wie kommt man jetzt sozusagen als legitimierter Leser an die Schlüssel, um nun auch an den Fingerabdruck herzukommen?
Also für die External Access Control ist eine sogenannte PKI, also eine Public Key Infrastructure, aufgebaut, die halt das Lesegerät und den Pass jeweils Schlüssel gespeichert sind. Also wo halt wirklich nur zertifizierte Lesegeräte dann auch auf diese Bereiche zugreifen können. Das heißt, es ist halt so gedacht, dass halt nicht jeder Staat, wo man halt einreißt, die Fingerabdrücke von deutschen oder EU-Bürgern auslesen kann, sondern halt nur Staaten, die halt mit der EU ein explizites Austauschabkommen haben.
Also tatsächlich dann mit der zertifizierenden Behörde, etwa bei uns in Deutschland eben, das BSI.
Also es werden halt dann regelmäßig Schlüssel ausgetauscht, die halt die Fingerabdruckdaten oder die Kommunikation verschlüsseln. Also halt wieder Public- und Secret-Key-Verfahren, so wie man es halt von PGP oder sowas kennt.
Also ein asymmetrisches Verschlüsselungsverfahren. Und mit welchem Schlüssel ist dann der Fingerabdruck verschlüsselt?
Der Fingerabdruck ist verschlüsselt mit dem Secret-Key des Document-Signers. Also der Dokumentenhersteller hat einen eigenen Key.
Also derjenige, der den Pass ausstellt.
Genau, also die Bundesdruckerei oder halt wer auch immer.
Also jetzt erstmal, wir wissen ja noch nicht, wer das in Zukunft sein wird.
Okay, also mein Fingerabdruck wird einmal aufgenommen, wird digitalisiert, in einen JPEG 2000 umgewandelt und dann hat die Druckerei einen Schlüssel und verschlüsselt.
Vielleicht sollten wir auf dieses ganze Aufnahmeverfahren nochmal explizit eingeflächelt.
Lass aber erstmal bei der Krypto bleiben. Dass nun mal klar ist, wie man da jetzt sozusagen rankommt. Also mich interessiert es einfach, man hat ja jetzt irgendwie eingesehen, dass diese Daten unter Umständen auch tatsächlich sensitiv sind. Also warum jetzt das Foto ausgerechnet das nicht sein soll, das haben wir dahingestellt, aber da sind sie jetzt wohl ein bisschen in diesem Deadlock mit, oh Gott, jetzt haben wir schon einen Standard, jetzt können wir es nicht mehr ändern, die Geister, die wir riefen. Aber jetzt Teil 2 sind sie schon ein bisschen vorsichtiger geworden. Und gut, jetzt ist der also verschlüsselt, das heißt, die Bundesdruckerei kann ihn immer auslesen, oder was?
Die Bundesdruckerei gibt halt den Schlüssel an die Lesegeräte, die an den Grenzen stehen, oder die halt dann vielleicht auch die Polizei in ihren mobilen Fingerabdruck- Lesegeräten irgendwann mal haben wird. Und mit diesem Geheimschlüssel werden dann halt praktisch die Daten von dem Pass ausgelesen, also entschlüsselt.
Das heißt, dieser Schlüssel, mit dem man das auslesen kann, wird also vielfach kopiert und in leicht klaubare Geräte übertragen.
Also, die Geräte sind halt schon sicherheitsspezifiziert, aber das heißt natürlich nicht, dass diese Schlüssel nicht irgendwann mal liegen werden. Also es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie liegen und das haben sie sich halt auch, also dass sie halt irgendwie veröffentlicht werden, das haben sie sich halt auch schon gedacht. Deswegen haben sie halt so ein abgestuftes Zertifizierungsverfahren genommen. Das heißt, die Schlüssel selber sind alle nur drei Monate gültig. Genau. Also zurückrufenden, genau. Und die Bundesdruckerei hat halt ein Schlüsselpaar, womit halt das Dokument, also der Fingerabdruck, verschlüsselt wird. Und diese Behörde ist halt nochmal übergeordnet vom BSI, dem Countrysigner, der halt für die Bundesdruckerei Schlüssel nochmal signiert. Also es hat so ein abgestuftes Schlüsselsignierungs...
Heißt das, dass dann die Auslesung nur online erfolgen kann?
Also beziehungsweise sehen wir online, das heißt, die Schlüssel werden halt alle drei Monate auf diese mobilen Geräte übertragen, an den Grenzstellen. Das ist auch nochmal ein sehr interessanter Punkt, wie die dort im Endeffekt hinkommen. Also natürlich behaupten, also die haben halt feste Standards irgendwie mit, denn da muss die und die Sicherheit beachtet werden. Aber im Endeffekt sind es halt so viele Stellen, über die dort diese Schlüssel gehen, dass man halt davon ausgehen kann, dass halt irgendwann dieser Schlüssel mal auch abhanden kommt.
Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, wie... Also angenommen, ich bin jetzt so ein mobiles Lesegerät. So und ich möchte jetzt gerne einen Pass auslesen und ich brauche jetzt auch mal dringend den Fingerabdruck, weil...
Lesegerät, wo bist du denn?
An der Grenze.
Ich finde mich in einem Polizeivagen, der Zollkontrolle oder sowas. Grenzschutz oder sowas, weiß ich nicht, oder sonst wo.
Vielleicht hätte er sein können, du bist in Pakistan.
Nee, ich bin jetzt erstmal in Deutschland. Ich versuche mir das jetzt erstmal nur so ein bisschen vorzustellen, weil mir erscheint es jetzt gerade ein bisschen sinnwidrig, wie ich die Fähigkeit verlieren kann, das auszulesen. Weil wenn ich jetzt diesen Schlüssel einmal habe, wie verliere ich dann sozusagen diesen Schlüssel? Also wie vergesse ich, dass ich den auslese?
Na der ist festgelegt, der ist halt irgendwie auf Datum, der ist halt wirklich mit einem Ablaufdatum unterschrieben, das nach drei Monaten ihn einfach ungültig macht.
Und wer weiß das aktuelle Datum? Das Lesegerät. Okay, aber wenn man jetzt diesen Schlüssel nimmt und das einfach ignoriert, dann...
Der Pass weiß natürlich auch. Aber der Pass weiß doch nicht, wie spät es ist.
Nee, nee, also der weiß natürlich, er hat keine interne Uhr.
Er hat keine interne Uhr, aber was halt angedacht ist, dass der Pass das Datum oder den Zeit-Campel des letzten authentifizierten Auslesevorgangs speichert.
Ah, er weiß, wie spät es mal war.
Genau. Das heißt, er kann sehen, ob es irgendwie noch innerhalb dieser drei Monate, der Dreimonatsfrist ist. Also ist das alles ein bisschen...
Das heißt, wenn man ein modifiziertes Lesegerät hat, wo drin steht irgendwie, es ist der 5. August 2090, dann ist das Ding sozusagen nicht mehr zu gebrauchen.
Naja, ich denke auch, dass es... Es kann sicherlich auch noch vorwärtsgucken. Es würde merken, wenn es ein Datum, was nicht nach dem Letzbenutzendatum ist. Ich denke, das könnte er auch bemerken.
Nicht nach dem Letzbenutzendatum?
Also das heißt, wenn man zum Beispiel rückwärts datiert.
Ja, ja, aber die Gefahr ist ja nach vorne. Genau, und die Zukunft datieren geht auf jeden Fall. Also man kann mit einem Lesegerät, was halt falsche Zeitstempel, ob es beabsichtigt oder nicht beabsichtigt ist, kann man auf jeden Fall Pässe eigentlich ungültig machen, wenn dieses Verfahren so angewendet wird.
Das ist ja nun auch eine falsche Datum. Das ist ja nun wirklich nichts, was ich nicht schon mal tausendfach auf dem Computer hatte. Normalerweise geht es ja immer auf den 1.
Aber es geht hier um Behörden. Vertraust du vielleicht den Behörden nicht?
Okay, aber ist jetzt sozusagen dieses Auslesen, muss online erfolgen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Pass auslese und ich bin ein Lesegerät im Polizeivagen, das Ding muss Internet haben.
Es muss irgendwann in den letzten drei Monate mal ein Internet gehabt haben, um den aktuellen Schlüssel zu haben.
Um den aktuellen Schlüssel zu haben.
Dann funktioniert es offline.
Aber der Schlüssel ändert sich doch nicht in den Pass. Der ist doch immer derselbe. Was hältst du deine Hand an die Stirn?
Na, es ist jetzt vielleicht ein ganz grundsätzliches Verständnisproblem. Die Prozedur, die jetzt beschrieben war, ist die Prozedur, wie man die Schlüssel für die Lesegeräte verteilt. Also, da hat nichts damit zu tun, dass sich da die Schlüssel auf den Pässen ändern wird.
Aber die Sicherheit basiert sozusagen darauf, dass diese Lesegeräte selber diese Schlüssel wieder vergessen. Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr, ich darf jetzt nicht mehr. Aber ich gehe ja sozusagen von diesem Konzept aus, dass, wenn so ein Lesegerät mal abhanden kommt, dass da sich ja zu dem Zeitpunkt auch ein Schlüssel drauf befindet, mit dem man halt einfach auslesen kann und mit dem man immer auslesen kann. Vorausgesetzt das Datum.
Das Datum auf dem Chip, auf dem Reisepass, ist halt nicht älter als drei Monate.
Also ein Pass, der sozusagen regelmäßig in Benutzung ist, dann ist es relativ wahrscheinlich, dass der dann irgendwann mit dem nicht mehr reden will. Verstehe. Also es gibt eine Methode, wie Schlüssel wieder aktualisiert werden können. Ist das alles sicher oder was?
Na klar, oder vertraust du den Behörden nicht? Also natürlich die entscheidende Frage ist dabei, an wen wird am Ende über diese PKI dann der Schlüssel verteilt. Also die Frage wird sein, wer wird den erhalten? Welche Drittländer sind das? Denn hier entscheidet sich ja, wer tatsächlich an diese als sensibler eingestuften Daten der Fingerabdrücke dann ran kann. Darum wird es eigentlich gehen. Das heißt, wird es primär zum Beispiel Länder sein, die bei uns unter Safe Harbor fallen, also die auch eine Datenschutzgesetzgebung haben, die zumindest nicht viel viel schlimmer ist als unsere eigene hier? Oder wird es eben auch, ich sag mal, schon wieder das Beispiel Pakistan sein, wo man davon ausgehen kann, dass es da keine Datenschutzgesetzgebung gibt, die man so nennen könnte? Das wird die entscheidende Frage sein.
Im Endeffekt spielt es nicht wirklich eine Rolle. Weil nämlich solange der Bürger nicht weiß, dass dieses Land nicht berechtigt ist, die Fingerabdrücke auszulesen, kann das Land natürlich trotzdem sagen, hier ist irgendwie unser Fingerabdruckleser, pack mal den Fingerabdruck darauf. Das heißt, man liest dann zwar nicht das digital gespeicherte Fingerabdruck aus dem Pass aus, aber man hat natürlich den live aufgenommenen Fingerabdruck von der Person. Und die deutsche Regierung hat gesagt, dass sie nicht bereit ist zu sagen, wer denn diese vertrauenswürdigen Länder sind. Das heißt, man weiß als deutscher Bürger nicht, ob man jetzt in Pakistan zum Beispiel seinen Fingerabdruck dort auflegen muss oder nicht. Man muss im Endeffekt den dort staatlichen Behörden vertrauen, dass sie sagen, wir dürfen das.
Und wir sehen ja heute schon, dass Länder, die zwar den biometrischen Reisepass nicht auslesen, aber dennoch eine funktionierende biometrische Infrastruktur schon jetzt monatelang an den Grenzen haben. Also Beispiel ist halt bekanntermaßen die USA, wo man ja nicht nur sein Gesichtsbild an der bei der Einreise abgenommen bekommt, sondern auch nur die Fingerabdrücke. Mittlerweile sind diese Datensätze auf über 100 Millionen Datensätze angewachsen. Also das ist ganz interessant. Ja, natürlich alle, die eingereist sind.
Auch die Amerikaner reisen ja ein.
Als Amerikaner musst du nicht durch diese Einreiseprozedur.
Aber um nochmal die Sache auf den Punkt zu bringen, das heißt, wenn die Daten kryptographisch halbwegs gut geschützt sind, was sie halt durchaus sind, da kann man den BSI sagen, da haben sie durchaus gute Arbeit geleistet oder die Herstabilisierung, ist man halt noch lange nicht davor gefeiert, dass sogenannte Schopenstaaten an die Fingerabdrücke rankommen. Und das wird halt einfach so passieren, dass halt trotz der guten Sicherung der Fingerabdrücke auf dem Chip halt diese Länder an die Daten, an die Fingerabdrücke rankommen werden und dann für was auch immer anders benutzt werden können. Also halt diese Fingerabdruckdaten, also je mehr sie... Genau, also je mehr halt Diometrie einzukällt in Identifizierungs-, Authentifizierungsmechanismen im Internethandel, wo auch immer, werden halt diese Daten auch immer wertvoller. Das heißt, es gibt halt heutzutage schon, genauso wie es Dateien mit Kreditkarten gibt, die halt irgendwie im Netz gehandelt werden, gibt es halt auch schon Daten mit Fingerabdruck, also Dateien mit Fingerabdruckdaten. Und es wird es natürlich in Zukunft noch vermehrt geben.
Also wir sind...
Gibt es denn schon, gibt es denn schon... Achso, na okay, es gibt ja den Reisepass noch nicht. Aber es wird natürlich spannend zu sehen sein, wann wirklich die ersten Datensätze von Pässen tatsächlich auch mal ins Netz kommen. Rechnet ihr damit, dass das schnell geht?
Ja, also da ist die... Die Frage ist, wie sinnvoll oder wie nützlich diese Daten für andere Anwendungen sind. Also sobald halt mit Biometrie... Also es gibt halt in Deutschland z.B. auch schon Läden, wo man mit Fingerabdrücken bezahlen kann. Und wenn das natürlich... Und Biergärten und Diskotheken. Also wenn das halt zunimmt... Ja, aber Videothek ist ja kein Angriffspunkt für organisierte Kriminalität. Und halt irgendwie diese Daten aus dem Internet zu ziehen. Ich meine, jetzt hat man da noch eine gewisse Hürde. Die werden halt noch relativ teuer sein. Und nur der OK irgendwie zugänglich. Aber je mehr die halt in die Öffentlichkeit treten, diese biometrischen Anwendungen, desto mehr werden natürlich diese Daten auch normalen Kriminellen zugänglich.
Also wir können uns natürlich schon in anderen Kontinenten angucken, wo eventuell die Entwicklung hingeht. Also wir haben z.B. in Südamerika bereits sehr viele Bankautomaten, die mit Fingerabdrücken bedient werden. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen eine andere Entwicklung als... Ausschließlich? Ja, das liegt daran, dass es noch recht hohe anerfabeten Quote gibt auf dem Land. Und dass also deshalb diese Fingerabdrucksysteme an Bankautomaten recht verbreitet sind. Hier sieht man auch jetzt schon, dass natürlich dann auch ein kommerzieller Wert solcher Fingerabdruckdaten besteht. Klar.
es werden auch keine Karten, doch es werden auch noch Karten ausgegeben.
Es gibt halt einfach diese Parallelen, Automaten, insbesondere... Genau. Das ist relativ bekannt. Wir sehen, etwa in Asien, kann man schon sehr gut beobachten, dass ganz viele Zugangssysteme mit Gesichtserkennung ziemlich innovationär verwendet werden. Besonders im betrieblichen Bereich. Also die großen Firmen, die da eben ihre 3000 oder 4000 Mitarbeiter morgens natürlich in biometrischen Schleusen hindurchleiten. Man kann die Entwicklung schon absehen. Und wir wissen ja, dass wir in Deutschland neben dem Reisepass ja auch den Personalausweis haben, der kommt. Das heißt, es wird eine Gesamterfassung der Bevölkerung werden. Und wir haben auch in Europa schon Standards. Die sogenannte European Citizen Card. Die als Standard schon erstmal da ist. Bisher ja erst einmal nur in Portugal probiert. Aber es gibt durchaus schon da den Trend, dass man auch gleich ganz Europa da... Er hat ein paar mehr Datenfelder.
Er ist halt immer noch national ausgestellt. Aber halt die Daten, die drauf sind, sind halt schon EU-weit standardisiert.
So wie der Führerschein.
So wie der Führerschein. Wo jetzt klar ist, jetzt betrifft es im Moment mit dem Elektronischen Reisepass vielleicht noch 5% oder 10% der Deutschen, die einen Reisepass haben, die reisen wollen. Aber haben Sie jetzt eigentlich schon beschlossen, oder so halbwegs... Ist noch in Diskussion in der Regierung. Aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Entscheidung bald fällt. Und ein Datum, was sich bis jetzt abzeichnet, ist 2009. Wird halt neuer Personalausweis eingeführt. Und halt mit denselben technischen Spezifikationen, wie jetzt der Reisepass. Also halt Gesichtsbild, Fingerabdruckbild, mit den ganzen kryptographischen Verfahren auch angewendet.
Also ist es immerhin möglich, dass die 2006 standardisierte European Citizen Card da eine Rolle spielen wird? Wir können es noch nicht wissen. Das heißt, es ist nur klar, dass ein neuer Personalausweis kommt. Aber wie konkret er technisch aussehen wird, ist unklar.
Aber Sie haben sich schon relativ deutlich dazu geäußert. Also es wird halt die Verfahren, also ich gehe davon aus, also ein Personalausweis ist ja auch als Reisedokument gültig. Das heißt, die logische Konsequenz ist einfach, nach dem Pass irgendwie auch den Personalausweis mit den gleichen Verfahren auszurüsten, um ihn halt dann auch an den Grenzen benutzen zu können. Und das Problem ist halt dort, dass halt nicht nur fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung betroffen sind, sondern im Endeffekt halt alle. Und da kommen wir dann halt wieder zu diesem großen Problem, dass man sich halt nicht mehr dagegen wehren kann, dass einem die Fingerabdrücke und die Gesichtsbilder und sowas abgenommen werden.
Denn eins der beiden Dokumente muss man ja haben. Und die Problematik besteht auch je wieder darin, dass offenbar aus den Fehlern, die beim Reisepass gemacht wurden, die einmal strukturell sind, aber die behaupteten, na eben Schwächen erstmal technischer Art, also in Bezug auf die Erkennungsleistung. Oder auch Schwächen, die eben der biometrischen Technik einfach inne wohnen. Probleme in Bezug auf zum Beispiel falsch Rückweisungsraten, die wir jetzt schon erwähnt haben. Probleme wie, dass man etwa die Kommunikation mithören kann, die wir jetzt besprochen haben. Also diese Sachen, die einfach bekannt sind mittlerweile, die werden hier nicht nochmal neu überdacht. Und die ganze Problematik, dass angeblich mehr Sicherheit mit diesen neuen biometrischen Dokumenten kommen könnte, wurde einfach übernommen, obwohl eigentlich mittlerweile ja klar ist, dass diese Argumentation eh jeglicher Grundlage entbehrt.
Also zum Beispiel das Problem mit dem Daten, also Kontaktlosen auslesen, also RFID zu verwenden, hätte man halt genauso gut umgehen können, wenn man halt kontaktbehaftete Kommunikation verwendet hat, also Smart Cards, die man irgendwo reinstecken muss, die halt ausgelesen werden. Da wäre halt ein großer Problemfall, halt dieses ganze Identitätsdiebstahl durch Abhören, durch irgendwie weit weg sein, halt erstmal gar nicht so einfach hinbekommen.
Weil man ja eh jetzt Kontakt herstellen muss und so weiter.
Richtig, man muss das Gerät auflegen und entsprechend wäre also eine preiswertere Technik möglich gewesen.
Und eine sichere.
Aber nun ja, man muss einfach sehen, dass auch die RFID-Industrie einfach gerade im Goldrausch ist. Also es war durchaus auch wieder ein Wirtschaftsförderungsprojekt. Und also trotzdem, wir eigentlich heute wissen, wo die Probleme mit all diesen Daten liegen und vor allen Dingen, dass sie auch damit erstmal aufgenommen werden. Denn es gibt ja vorher keine biometrische Vollerfassung der Deutschen. Die werden gar nicht bedacht. Also hier wird diese sinnfreie Argumentation, das würde mir Sicherheit bringen, einfach übernommen.
Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt wirklich mal auf die Technik eingehen, die zum Fingerabdruck abnehmen und melden.
Das haben wir noch nicht besprochen, das stimmt. Wobei mich das nicht nur für den Fingerabdruck interessieren würde, sondern auch für die Gesichtserfassung als solches. Du hattest ja erwähnt, dass du, wo warst du, in Malaysia, auch schon solche Systeme an der Grenze direkt im Einsatz gesehen hast.
Wenn man sich heutzutage, also noch vor dem 1. November, einen Reisepass in Deutschland beantragt, muss man das Gesichtsbild, also ein Foto, abgeben, was dann digital in dem Elektronischen Reisepass gespeichert wird. Das heißt, man kann, wie früher auch, ein Foto, gibt es dort ab, die werden eingestand, werden diese Qualitätsprüfungen unterzogen. Und dann wird es halt digital auf dem Pass gespeichert. Mit den ganzen Einschränkungen wie Frontalbild, Start-Halbprofil und so weiter. Beim Fingerabdruck läuft das alles ein bisschen anders. Und zwar gibt es dort in den Meldemelde selber Lesegeräte. Das heißt, man gibt den Fingerabdruck genau in der Meldestelle ab. Das heißt, man geht dorthin, sagt, ich will einen neuen Pass haben, gibt halt weiterhin sein digitales Foto ab, weil es natürlich trotzdem noch drin ist. Und muss dann jetzt, also ab 1. November, zwei Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Also bei der Polizei heißt das erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung.
Ist auf jeden Fall so, ja. Also kann man halt nicht anders sagen.
Welche muss man abgeben?
Tja, da wird es nämlich interessant. Wir haben bereits jetzt Erfahrungen gesammelt, denn seit einigen Monaten gibt es diese Probemeldeämter, wo also schon probehalber einige dieser Pässe und die ganze Prozedur mit dem Fingerabdruck schon mal getestet wurden. Hierfür gab es dann eine spezielle Incentivierung. Man hat nämlich fünf Euro weniger bezahlt für seinen Reisepass, damit man freiwillig seine Fingerabdrücke abgibt. Und sie haben also zunächst mal die Planung, dass sie acht dieser biometrischen Merkmale Fingerabdruck durchprobieren. Und zwar nehmen sie den kleinen Finger nicht, aber die restlichen Finger. Und zwar immer dann können diese acht Finger auf den Sensor gelegt werden, wenn zum Beispiel beim Versuch des Zeigefingers, mit dem man beginnt, nicht so gute Bilder anbietet werden. Man stellt sich also vor, eventuell ist zum Beispiel durch Abrieb die Minutienstärke nicht so gut, man hat also nicht so ein tolle Bild.
Also lass mal ganz von Anfang an beginnen. Also man geht dorthin, man zeigt erst mal seine Hände vor. Also die Meldestellenbeamte ist verpflichtet, zu erst mal sagen, ob man zum Beispiel eine Trappe aufgeklebt hat oder was auch immer. Also ob man versucht hat, dieses Verfahren zu betrügen, also irgendwie sich mit falschen bimitischen Lärkmalen.
Das vergessen bestimmt die Hälfte schon mal zu fragen, ne?
Kann man davon ausgehen. Also wir sind dann auf jeden Fall auch, wenn es umgesetzt wird, an Berichten sehr interessiert, wie es tatsächlich umgesetzt wird. Okay, also die Meldbeamte soll nach der, also nach dem Gesetz...
Die Kontaktadresse ist übrigens Chaosradio. www.sccc.de kann man an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz einwerfen. Solltet ihr also einen Pass beantragen, oder jetzt beantragen und müsst eure Fingerabdrücke abgeben, wie wir es sind, an Berichten sehr interessiert.
Also auch jetzt schon. Also sobald, also wenn die Sensoren auf den Meldbeamten sind, was halt jetzt teilweise schon der Fall ist, kann man auch jetzt schon Fingerabdruck, Passe beantragen. Also man ist noch nicht verpflichtet, aber sie werden einen wahrscheinlich schon fragen, ob wir irgendwie nicht mal dieses tolle neue Gerät ausprobieren dürfen mit deinen Fingerabdrücken. Das heißt, wenn da halt jemand das vorhat, dann auf jeden Fall vielleicht vorher uns kontaktieren. Wir kommen irgendwie auch gerne mit, wenn wir jemanden finden, der da in der Nähe ist. Also wir sind halt wirklich brenntransfiziert, weil wir halt selber auch nicht zu einer Theorie wissen, wie das Verfahren ablaufen soll.
Okay, das bringt mich zur Frage, hat denn die Biometrie-Gruppe auch irgendwie noch eine Sammel-E-Mail-Adresse, wo man sich melden kann?
Ja, epass.ccc.de, also epass.ccc.de Ah, okay, das ist ja noch sehr viel besser.
Also wenn ihr sozusagen vor habt, da demnächst mal hinzulatschen und bereit werdet, ein paar Tipps mitzunehmen, wir helfen dann auch bei der späteren, eventuellen Deaktivierung des funkernden Chips.
Wir fassen eine Serviceleistung über mccc.de Erstmal die Technik noch ein bisschen näher beschreiben.
Also Hände hoch und keine Folien auf den Fingerkappen haben.
Welche auch da Trappen drauf sind. Dann ist der nächste Punkt zu prüfen, ob halt überhaupt, ob die Finger halt verwendbar sind. Also ob man halt zum Beispiel Pflaster drauf hat, ob man eine Hand abgeschnitten hat, ob man irgendwie einzelne Finger verloren hat. Das muss halt vorher auch angegeben werden.
Oder zum Beispiel man kann auch mal sich doll geschnitten haben.
Also das sind halt alles so Fragen.
Man kann sich auch gerade vorhin doll geschnitten haben. Entschuldigung, ich musste durch diesen Dornbusch.
Man hat gerade sein Modellflugzeug zu Ende geklebt und hat halt überall Kleber auf den Fingern.
Ja, ich habe Jesus Gesicht auf einer Bananenschale gesehen.
Okay, also das heißt, es wird erstmal überprüft werden, ob welche Finger überhaupt zur Verfügung stehen. Und dann ist das Verfahren so, dass mit der rechten Hand angefangen wird. Die Reihenfolge ist Zeigefinger, Daumen, Mittelfinger, Ringfinger. Ringfinger, Mittelfinger. Genau, der kleine Finger fällt aus.
Genau.
Weil er ist zu klein, hat zu wenig Merkmale. Das heißt, auf jeden Fall sind im Zweifelsfall... Im Zweifelsfall 8 Finger betroffen.
Du musst dir merken, welche sie genommen haben.
Das heißt, normalerweise fangen wir an mit dem rechten Zeigefinger. Dann ist das Verfahren so, dass der Finger dreimal aufgelegt werden muss auf den Sensor. Und dann gibt es einen Qualitätswert, der sagt, ob der Fingerabdruck irgendwie gut ist oder nicht.
Also praktisch wird vom Computer dieser Wert ausgegeben. Der Beamte checkt nur, ob ein bestimmter Wert überschritten wird oder nicht. Das ist für den sehr einfach.
Der Schwellwert ist 50%, haben Sie uns auf der CeBIT gesagt. Das ist interessant für die spätere Anwendung. Wenn er erkannt wird oder sagt, der Schwellwert ist irgendwie gut, dann wird der Finger von der rechten Hand genommen. Dann geht es mit der linken Hand weiter. Da hat er auch wieder Zeigefinger, Daumen, Mittelfinger, Ringfinger.
Und wenn es mit allen 8 nicht klappt, dann kriegt man keinen Pass.
Ah, nix da, hast du dir gedacht. Das ist aber leider nicht so. Wollen wir mal Tim raten lassen, was Sie machen, wenn keiner dieser 8 Finger den Schwellwert überschreitet?
Also rat mal.
Geben wir mal einen Hinweis.
Kein Pass ist natürlich unsinnig, weil es geht nicht.
Es muss gehen, ja. Man muss echt seine Füße da drauflegen? Ich dachte schon an eine andere Körperteile.
Nein, man muss nicht seine Füße da drauflegen. Wir haben dich bewusst in die Irre geführt.
Fura.
Nein, die Antwort ist ganz schlecht. Sie nehmen dann einfach von diesen erzielten Schwellwerten den besten. Das heißt, wenn der möglicherweise nur 20 ist...
Wenn alle 8 scheiße sind, dann nehmen Sie den besten.
Dann nehmen Sie den besten von den schlechten.
Eine ganz schöne Sicherheitssimulation ist im Endeffekt nicht mehr eine Simulation, weil sie dann auch schlechte Merkmale zur Identifizierung von Leuten nehmen.
Aber das bedeutet ja im Prinzip, dass man dann auch ein echtes Problem hat später, oder? Das ist doch ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, dass man jetzt acht Finger durchprobiert.
Entschuldige, wir haben ein paar Senioren in Deutschland.
Wir haben elf Prozent Leute.
Zehn Prozent, die generell... Also die betrifft es dann meistens nicht einen Finger. Ein Finger ist, wenn man sich mal geschnitten hat oder den abgehackt hat. Aber gerade diese Personengruppe der Senioren, die sehr dünne Haut hat, wo die Sensoren Probleme haben, die Fingerabdruckbilder abzunehmen, das betrifft natürlich dann alle Achtfinger.
Man nennt so was Diskriminierung.
Und diese Fingerabdruck-Albinos, die überhaupt keine Linien haben, wie häufig sind die so vertreten?
Das ist schon minimal.
Also ich kenne jetzt keine medizinischen Studien darüber.
Okay, also es ist kein...
Aber auf jeden Fall, es gibt auch den Fall, dass halt keine Fingerabdrücke vorhanden sind. Also dass da nicht ein Schwellwert mit irgendwie 10 Prozent oder sowas genommen wird, sondern es gibt halt auch den Fall, wir haben keine. Das liegt übrigens im Ermessen des Meldestellenbeamten. Also wenn ihr halt sagt, nach dem Zeigefinger und dem Daumen, die muss ja prüfen, wenn da aber irgendwie keine Bilder abgenommen werden können, dann kann der Beamte sagen, ja okay, dann hast du halt keine Fingerabdrücke, hier kriegst du einen Pass mit dem Vermehrer, keine Fingerabdrücke. Das heißt, wenn man halt irgendwie einen freundlichen Meldestellenbeamten findet oder ihn halt irgendwie ein paar Euro rüber schiebt und sagt, ich will dir meine Fingerabdrücke nicht abgeben.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt. Doch. Nein, wir können ja nicht zur Bestechung aufrufen.
Hab ich nicht. Ich hab nur eine Inventualität angeführt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall davon auszugehen, ich meine, so wie ich Beamte in diesen, wie soll ich sagen, bürgernahen Zentren kenne, die wollen sich natürlich auch nicht ewig mit solchen Prozeduren aufhalten. Also wenn die da so eine lange Liste haben von Sachen, die sie alle berücksichtigen müssen und dann klappt irgendwas nicht, dann kommen sie wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen ins Schwitzen und irgendwann nehmen sie dann den Weg des geringsten Widerstandes. Also das halte ich schon für durchausdünnbar.
Wir haben ja gesehen, wie bei den Gesichtsbildern gelaufen ist. Denn da gab es ja am Anfang auch einige Probleme, als im November 2005 gestartet hat.
Sagen wir mal ein paar Zahlen.
Also es war einfach am Anfang so, dass ein Großteil dieser Passbilder nicht in diese Schablonen passte.
Also es waren 80 Prozent.
Was lag an den Schablonen?
Es lag an den Fotografen, die damit nicht klarkamen.
Also einfach die Informationen waren noch nicht so rum.
Noch nicht ihre Filter oder ihre Programme fertig hatten. Die Köpfe wieder zu schrumpfen.
Eierkopf-Plugin.
Es lag zum Teil auch daran, dass die Mädebehörden noch gar nicht richtige Schablonen teilweise hatten. Also da waren schon viele einfach Kinderschuhproblematiken. Und es gab auch einfach schlicht viele Bürger, die kamen da halt nicht mit einem Frontalfoto, weil niemand hatte ihnen gesagt, dass jetzt biometrieldos ist.
Aber das zeigt auch mal wieder, wie leichtsinnig hier die Regierung oder wie auch immer an die Sache herangegangen ist. Die Informationskampagne war halt echt mies. Also man wusste halt gar nicht, dass jetzt der neue Reisepass ist. Man wusste nicht, dass er doppelt so viel kostet wie vorher. Man ist halt mit den alten Passbildern angekommen und sie wurden dann halt auch abgenommen. Also es ist halt praktisch ein Feldtest am lebenden Objekt, also eine Operation am offenen Herzen sozusagen.
Das kann man auch deshalb sagen, weil ja die Anzahl der Probanden in dem Feldtest, den sie durchgeführt haben, sowieso viel zu gering war, um echte Aussagen zu machen. Wir haben mal die Erfahrung gemacht vor dem Start des Projektes, dass aufgrund der recht breiten Kritik von A, Bürgerrechtlern, aber B, auch aus der Wissenschaft, dass einfach am Ende das Bundesinnenministerium gar nichts mehr gesagt hat und auch die Journalisten im Prinzip, die mal eine kritische Frage gestellt haben, selbst auf, sag ich mal, sehr einfachem Niveau kritisiert haben, einfach keine Antworten mehr bekommen haben. Entsprechend war natürlich auch der Kenntnisstand der Bevölkerung dann schlecht, weil die große Werbekampagne für den IPAS dann eigentlich so nicht mehr durchgeführt wurde. Da wurden die Schotten dichtgemacht bei der Pressestelle des Bundesministeriums.
Bei der Informationsveranstaltung, ja.
Es gab eine zentrale Veranstaltung für die Presse in der Bundesdruckerei hier in Berlin, in diesem Gebäude.
Also kurz vor November 2005.
Genau. Ich glaube, das war nur so ein Monat vor der Einführung. Da sollten insbesondere die Pressevertreter informiert werden über die Technik. Dazu wurde sogar angeboten, dass man sich in der Bundesdruckerei befindlichen Showroom begeben konnte, wo sie allerhand Geräte zum Probieren ausgestellt hatten. Und nun waren da einige Vertreter zum einen von BMI, dann aber auch von der Bundesdruckerei und vom BSI da und haben da kurze Präsentationen gegeben. Und natürlich war die Bitkom da, die als Bundesvereinigung vieler betroffener Unternehmen da gesprochen hat und so weiter. Na ja, und das zeigte sich heute immer. Alle waren am Anfang sehr stolz, aber dann kamen halt so die ersten kritischen Fragen. Zum Beispiel? Also etwa war ja der CCC der Anwesen, der da Fragen gestellt hat oder auch die Humanistische Union, die ein paar juristische Fragestellungen hatte. Die wurden einfach immer kritischer, die Fragen. Und am Ende haben sie dann einfach diese Fragestation beendet, aber sie wurden die Fragen schlicht nicht los. Weil nach dieser Fragerunde wurde man ja in Gruppen durch diesen Showroom geführt. Und hat sich dann so ergeben, dass im Prinzip die Journalisten einfach die Fragen dort gestellt haben. Nämlich etwa, was denn diese Lesegeräte kosten. Vor denen standen die glitzernden Geräte. Bei jedem einzelnen Gerät wurde einfach mal nachgefragt. Und immer wieder war die Antwort, ja wissen wir nicht, können wir keine Aussage machen? Und am Ende haben sie die Show abgebrochen, weil ihnen die Fragen zu kritisch wurden. Da muss ich vorstellen, dass da selbst Journalisten vom Guten Rat, also dieser Zeitschrift Guter Rat, da waren, die einfach echt kritische Fragen gestellt haben. Was ist das? Eine Zeitschrift, eine sehr kleine, Guter Rat, eine Verbraucherzeitschrift.
Okay.
Also nur mal zu sagen, da waren nicht nur die Süddeutsche und die FAZ und der Spiegel, sondern da waren halt...
Auf einmal fanden sie es dann alle toll, mal richtig schön Fragen zu fragen.
Richtig.
Also wie wenn sie ganz schön wissen, muss wieder im Aufwind.
Und diese gab es ja gerade wieder, diese Veranstaltung, jetzt am 2. Oktober bei der Bundeskommission. Da waren sie aber ein bisschen restriktiver.
Warst du da auch?
Da waren sie etwas restriktiver mit den Leuten, die sie dazulassen.
Alles klar. Das heißt, da war wieder die humanistische Union noch der CCC geladen?
Das ist richtig.
Ja, das kennen wir ja schon aus der griechischen Göttergeschichte, dass das nicht sehr produktiv ist, wenn man das Chaos nicht auf die Party legt. Ja, ich finde auch. Viel zu kritisch.
Zu den Kosten noch mal was zu sagen. Wo gesagt wurde, sie machen halt keine Aussagen zu den jeweiligen Geräten. Das ist halt auch genauso wie diese Journalisten, nicht mal mit Antworten zu füttern, sagen sie halt auch, wir können keine Aussage über die Kosten treffen. Also die Bundesregierung sagt das zu jeder Anfrage, die sich mit dem E-Pass beschäftigt. Dazu können wir noch keine Aussagen treffen. Das heißt, sie haben nicht mal vorhinein abgeschätzt, was es tatsächlich kosten wird. Sie wissen nicht, wie viel die Fingerabdrucksensoren kosten werden. Sie wissen nicht, wie viel die Sensoren und die Lesegeräte an den Grenzen kosten, wie viel die Schulung der Beamten kostet. Das heißt, das ist einfach ein total offenes Millionengrab praktisch.
Vor allen Dingen, es gab halt im Laufe der Zeit bereits eigentlich ab 2004 schon immer wieder Anfragen, die eigentlich eine an die Bundesregierung, die diese Kostenfrage immer wieder gestellt haben. Denn die einzigen Zahlen, die wir haben, sind vom Dezember 2003 aus diesem TAP-Bericht, der noch am Auftrag der Bundesregierung erstellt wurde. Also die Frage, was denn eigentlich dieses Projekt kostet. Und da sind so halt insgesamt 669 Millionen für einmalige Kosten und 610 Millionen laufende Kosten pro Jahr angegeben. Aber diese Zahlen sind natürlich uralt. Das heißt, Dezember 2003, da hat sich nochmal sehr viel getan an der Technik. Die sind also gar nicht mehr aktuell. Wir können davon ausgehen, dass die heute nicht höher sind. Natürlich nicht. Es gibt einfach immer noch keine Antworten.
Also vielleicht gibt es internen Kostenschätzungen, aber da ist ganz, ganz klar die Aussage nach Oßen. Wir können dazu keine Aussagen treffen.
Das heißt, wir kriegen diese große, keine-Sicherheit-bringende, riesenhafte biometrische Vollerfassung. Und sie sagen uns nicht mal, was das uns kosten wird, denn wir bezahlen es ja auch. Weil es wird ja immer wieder behauptet, dass über die erhöhten Kosten des Reisepasses ein Großteil der Kosten für die Einführung gedeckt sei. Wir haben aber überhaupt keine Beweise dafür.
Das klingt doch nicht sehr viel.
120 statt 30.
59.
60 statt 30 Euro.
Genau.
Für 10 Jahre Gültigkeit.
Also wir haben noch einen Express-Pass, der ist ein bisschen teurer, der kostet 94.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall schon so ansatzweise Aussagen von den Ländern, die halt irgendwie, also die ja im Endeffekt das Geld für die Meldestellen und sowas bezahlen müssen für die neuen Geräte. Und die sagen halt auch relativ eindeutig, dass die Kosten damit nicht gedeckt sind mit den Zuschüssen, die sie vom Staat dafür kriegen.
Also wir haben in Deutschland 5.300 Meldempter, die muss man erstmal bestücken, nicht wahr?
Mit Geräten weiß man nicht jetzt, was die Dinger kosten.
Also wir haben noch keine Aussage dazu öffentlich gesehen. Also es gab auch...
Und wer muss die kaufen? Also ist das regional dann? Oder für so ein zentrales Dokument? Das muss ja eigentlich der Bund dann...
Eigentlich geht die Bundesdokumente damit in Vorkasse. Also es ist halt alles ein bisschen noch undurchsichtig. Es gibt halt, wie gesagt, keine wirklichen Aussagen dazu. Aber das ist eigentlich schon vom Bund oder von der Bundesdokumente. Das sollte dann teilweise finanziert werden. Also die Geräte, die wirkliche Hardware.
Wir müssen mal solche Detailinformationen über den Informationsfreiheitsgesetz anlangen.
Nichts genaues weiß man. Ja, finde ich auch so. Jetzt wollte ich aber noch mal kurz auf deine Erfahrungen jetzt mit der Bilderfassung generell. Ja, weil über Fingerabdruck haben wir jetzt viel geredet. Ich meine, es gibt ja dieses schöne alte Video, das wir vor Jahren schon mal gemacht haben im Club, was auch bei KakaoTV zu finden ist, wie leicht man einen Fingerabdruck nachmachen kann.
Was übrigens auch international angefragt wurde. Sie hatten gerade wieder eine Anfrage von französischen Journalisten, der explizit darüber was schreiben will, der sehr froh war, dass wir ihm das Video schicken konnten und er das auf jeden Fall auch einbauen will.
Wir waren in Deutschland eigentlich in fast allen Fernsehsenden damit.
Es ist auch ein schönes Ding so. Muss man sicherlich auch noch mal aktualisieren, wenn es wieder neu ist.
Wir haben das ja mit X mal. Bei jeder Fernsehsende hat es ja in der Regel noch mal neu gedreht, weil sie natürlich die alten Materialien nicht verwenden wollten. Wir sind auch mittlerweile relativ schnell, nicht wahr? Also wir haben einfach die Prozeduren beschleunigt, damit die nicht immer so lange im Club rumhängen.
Also ich will ganz kurz noch mal zwei Fakten vom Anmeldeämter. Wenn man halt seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben muss, einfach mal ein paar Zahlen nennen. Also man hat auf jeden Fall 500 DPI hat der Scanner selber, der Fingerabdruckscanner, das ist halt so FBI-Vorgaben. Acht wird Farbtiefe und der muss halt regelmäßig gereinigt werden und auch kalibriert werden.
Aber Farbtiefe ist eine Graustufenscanner, oder?
Aber auf jeden Fall sind halt für diese ganzen Qualitätssachen sind halt die Meldestellen verantwortlich. Wenn sie das halt irgendwie nicht hinkriegen, also irgendwie vergessen oder was auch immer, dann sind halt eventuell die Bilder trotz guter Fingerabdrücke trotzdem schlecht und das fällt halt irgendwann erst später auf. Also so nach drei Monaten in der Regel, wenn halt dann die Bundeszuckerei eventuell sagt, irgendwie da gibt es halt ein Meldamt, wo ganz viele schlechte Bilder herkommen, dann guckt doch mal nach. Aber bis dahin sind auf jeden Fall halt Bürger, die eigentlich auch gute Fingerabdrücke haben, die eigentlich dann keine Probleme an den Grenzen haben sollten, trotzdem mit schlechten Fingerabdrücken im Pass gespeichert und haben dann im Endeffekt wieder Grenzen, also halt Probleme. Das heißt, diese ganzen Qualitätssicherungs-Sachen sind halt... Nee, das ist das Vorgehen, also mit denen irgendwie, dass es qualitativ überprüft wird in der Meldestelle und dass die für die Reinigung verantwortlich sind und so weiter.
Aber ob es jetzt wirklich dazu führen wird, dass schlechte Wartung zu so schlechten Ergebnissen dauernd wird?
Wir kennen ja schon die Ergebnisse aus der BIP2-Studie, wo ja selbst in diesem kurzen Zeitraum von acht Wochen sich schon gezeigt hat, dass die Sensoren manchmal Probleme aufwiesen. Das ist durchaus zu erwarten.
Durch Alterung oder durch Verdreckung oder alles Mögliche.
Oder auch schlichte Zerkratzen.
Also Temperaturunterschiede werden immer angeführt. So Feuchtigkeit und das häufige Benutzen. Oder Matriarchie. Wenn zum Beispiel ein Arbeiter kommt, der vorher im Mörtel rumgerührt hat und jetzt einen neuen Pass haben will, dann ist das natürlich ungünstig für den Fingerabdrucksensor.
Wir sollten vielleicht eh hier alle depressiv werden. Mal eine Sache erwähnen, die wir bisher noch nicht vergessen haben. Das müssen wir vielleicht doch ein bisschen zum Atmen.
Ich wollte es aber zum Schluss die Gegenmaßnahmen.
Nein, es geht nicht um die Gegenmaßnahmen. Also ich werde das nur mal erwähnen. Wir haben uns hier über diese Fingerabdrücke und Gesichtsbitter geredet. Ich wollte das mal ganz grundsätzlich sagen. Dieser Pass ist ein gültiges Reisedokument, wenn der Chip in einer Passtecke kaputt ist. Das heißt, funktioniert dieser Chip nicht, dann bleibt dieser Reisepass über die gesamte Laufzeit gültig. Wie man eventuell den Chip dazu kriegt, dass er nicht mehr funkt, können wir am Ende besprechen. Aber ich wollte es mal erwähnen, um auch mal klarzumachen, wie dem nicht diese Sicherheitsprozedur ist, weil nämlich dieser Pass trotzdem vollständige Gültigkeit hat.
Das würden wir doch auch erwarten, dass er dann immer noch gültig ist, wenn die Elektronik versagt, oder?
Aber was machen wir dann?
Also im Endeffekt ist das wirklich...
Ich weiß nicht. Um Dinge zu speichern, die man so vorher nicht hat speichern können. Um Dinge auszuwerten, die... keine Ahnung. Ich meine, ich kann dir das nicht so gut beantworten.
Er ist einfach kein guter Politiker, oder?
Ich bin überhaupt gar kein Politiker. Ich bin ein Podcaster. Das ist was ganz anderes.
Also ich würde sagen, da würde ich auf jeden Fall ganz gern zum Schluss drauf nochmal eingehen, was es so alles für Möglichkeiten gibt, sich dagegen zu wehren auf die eine oder andere Weise.
Ja, wir können da auch jetzt gerne drauf ankommen, weil so langsam müssen wir auch mal zum Schluss kommen. Ich versuche mich nur gerade zu erinnern, ob wir gerade aus irgendeinem wichtigen Thema ausgestiegen sind. Und ich möchte, also ich denke, dass wir die Fingerabdrücken haben wir jetzt glaube ich sehr umfassend gesehen. Und Fingerabdrücke sind ja auch so ein bisschen der Klassiker. Das kennt jeder schon immer aus alten Krimis. Und da kommt der Detektiv mit seinem kleinen Pinsel und so weiter. Also das ist schon immer so ein kriminalistisches Objekt, ist es klar. Was aber sich immer noch sehr schwer vorstellen lässt, das ist die Möglichkeit eben mit seiner Gesichtsbiometrie, also mit den Daten, die auch jetzt schon im Pass drin sind, erkannt zu werden. Was ist denn da der Stand der Dinge? Also wie gut kann mein Gesicht erkannt werden mit diesen 15 Kilobyte JPEG 2000, die auf dem Pass sind? Geht das nur, wenn ich jetzt stramm nicht lächelnd vor einer Kamera stehe mit der richtigen Ausleuchtung im Hintergrund? Oder reicht es schon, wenn ich irgendwie so im Halbprofil auf dem Alex mit den anderen Punks so auf dem Brunnen liege und die Kamera aus 200 Metern Entfernung gucke mal vorbei?
Also eigentlich kann man da ein klares, das erste ist der Fall, der aktuelle Fall irgendwie sagen. Also man muss halt wirklich sehr gezielt die Umgebungsbedingungen einhalten. Man muss halt wirklich in dem neutralen Gesichtsausdruck in die Kamera blicken. Es darf halt irgendwie keine Lampe oben ausgefallen sein. Also die Lichtbedingungen müssen halt wirklich übereinstimmen. Dann hat man Erkennungsraten. Also die kann man immer nicht davon reden, dass sie halt akzeptabel sind. Die sind dann vielleicht so bei 80 Prozent, 70 Prozent. Oder lass es vielleicht 90 Prozent sein, wenn es hochkommt. Aber es sind halt immer noch für wirkliche Terroristenfindung oder für Kontrolle von allen 340 Millionen Europäern einfach keine Zahlen, mit denen man arbeiten kann.
Aber ist es denn vorstellbar, dass sich die Technik da einentwickelt? Weil das ist im Prinzip genauer, was ich am Anfang so meinte. Also auf der einen Seite gibt es so dieses Szenario, oh Gott, wir werden jetzt alle gespeichert und erfasst. Und jetzt können sie uns irgendwie bei jedem Poops aus der Ferne automatisch entdecken und exekutieren, oder was weiß ich. Auf der anderen Seite funktioniert das alles nicht. Also wo, dann müssen wir jetzt wohl doch noch auf meins eingehen. Wie soll man das gewichten?
Ich sehe es eigentlich prinzipiell ein bisschen anders. Also klar sehen wir heute die Werte, die wir jetzt ja eben erwähnt haben. Aber man kann heute schon sehr deutlich sehen, wo die Zukunft hingehen wird. Wir reden jetzt nur über 2D-Gesichtserkennung, also wie die in den Pässen eben sind, nicht über 3D. Man muss sich überlegen, dass ein gutes digitales Foto mit einer guten homogenen Lichtsituation heute natürlich sehr leicht hunderte von Fotos sein kann, wenn man es durch eine Bildbearbeitung schiebt und einfach Lichteffekte hinzufügt. Insofern sieht die Zukunft, es gibt heute bereits solche Systeme, natürlich so aus, dass aus einem guten Bild sehr viele Bilder erzeugt werden können. Hunderte.
Also eventuell auch mit den Beleuchtungsbedingungen, die dich am Brunnen lümmelnd irgendwie aus 200 Metern an Entfernung aufgenommen darstellen. Das heißt, sie nehmen das Original-Digital-Bild und verfremden das so, dass halt die Lichtbedingungen dann den Bedingungen angepasst sind.
Ah, du meinst gar nicht, dass ich erkannt werde, sondern dass man einfach so eine schöne Vorlage hat und mein Bild einfach in ein beliebiges Bild hineinmatscht.
Schon mit dem Ziel, dich zu erkennen. Aber sie können einfach aus diesem einen guten Bild sehr viele machen. Klar, also man muss sich angenommen, du bist halt was von einer Überwachungskamera aufgenommen und die Sonne scheint dich halt von schräg oben an. Dann kann man natürlich aus dem guten, einen biometrischen Bild, den man macht, eins dabei haben, wo genau diese Lichtsituation vorher schon berechnet wurde. Das ist natürlich heute nur noch ein Klick. Entsprechend kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass ein gutes Bild besonders in einer recht naheliegenden Zukunft eben auch solche normalen Lichtsituationen, wie sie in der Umwelt vorherrschen und wie sie mit relativ guten Optiken von Videoüberwachungskameras eben aufgenommen werden, möglicherweise abbieglichen werden. Natürlich werden die Erkennungsraten nie super hoch sein.
Du musst das noch mal einfacher erklären.
Das ist ja eigentlich sehr einfach zu vorstellen.
Ich glaube auch einfach nicht, dass das relevant ist. Weil du halt immer dann trotzdem viele Bilder hast und damit die Erkennungsraten natürlich, weil du vergleichst ja trotzdem gegen die vielen Bilder. Und wenn du halt irgendeine Defikation machen willst, das heißt irgendwie ein 1 zu n-Abgleich, eine Person aus einer Gruppe rausgreifen will, das funktioniert dann damit nicht.
Also es geht ja im Prinzip bei dem Pass immer darum, dass man vergleicht das aktuelle Bild und das Gespeicherte. Und worauf sich Starbug jetzt bezieht, ist natürlich die Frage, kann man auch ein aktuell aufgenommenes Bild mit einer ganzen Datenbank vergleichen, wie man es mal im Film sieht. Dann rastet er die Datenbank durch und dann zack, ist der Verdächtige dabei. Darum würde es ja gehen. Ich habe solche Systeme schon gesehen, wo aus einem Bild eine ganze Anzahl von Bildern generiert wird, um einfach die Möglichkeit zu der Erkennung von einem aktuell aufgenommenen Bild zu erhöhen.
Es geht explizit darum, dass man halt... Also biometrische Gesichtserkennung hat halt Probleme, wenn die Lichtbedingungen nicht konstant sind. Also nicht so sind, wie sie bei der Originalaufnahme gemacht wurden. Das kann man halt entweder so umgehen oder irgendwie so anpassen, dass man halt die Lichtbedingungen an dem Erkennungsort genauso macht, wie sie halt an dem Aufnahmeort, an dem ehemaligen Aufnahmeort gewesen sind. Oder dass man halt die Bilder manipuliert, dass sie halt den Lichtbedingungen entsprechen, die an dem Ort sind.
Aber ich glaube, das geht doch zu weit. Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, ist, geht es nicht eigentlich nur darum, zu wissen, wo die Augen sind, wie lang die Nase ist, wie breit der Mund ist und wie der Abstand zueinander ist. Ich meine, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das so sehr von den Lichtbedingungen abhängig ist.
Die 2D-Gesichtserkennung ist explizit, also sehr stark, vom Lichtbedingungen abhängig. Da gibt es halt wirklich Fakten, die sagen, wenn das Licht nicht frontal kommt, sondern von links, dann droppt die Erkennungsrate von 50 auf 10 Prozent oder sowas. Das ist auf jeden Fall der Fakt. Aber ich sehe halt eher die Zukunft der Gesichtserkennung in 3D-Gesichtserkennung, wo halt irgendwie durch dreidimensionale...
Beide Bilder abgegeben werden müssen. Nämlich dann kommt wieder das Halbprofil zusätzlich mit der Front.
Und dann hat man schon mal... Na wie auch immer, dann wirklich 3D-Bilder. Also es wird heutzutage halt schon... Es gibt erste Systeme, die das halt benutzen, die halt wirklich dreidimensionale Bilder des Gesichts abnehmen, um halt einfach diese Lichteffekte rauszurechnen. Also die dann halt keine Rolle mehr spielen, weil du hast halt wirklich nur das 3D-Bild. Und derzeit sind die Erkennungsraten noch schlechter als 2D-Erkennung, aber das ist halt so ein Verfahren, wo man halt durchaus noch mal eine bessere Erkennungsratenlampe und ein Faktor 10 oder so was irgendwie in Zukunft erreichen kann.
2D-Systeme hast du im Einsatz gesehen? Jetzt haben wir das Thema. Malaysia, du warst da. Und dort waren diese... Nein, jetzt Constanze nicht. Du warst da und dort ist das im Einsatz.
Da sind Fingerabdrucksysteme im Einsatz.
Ah, Fingerabdrucksysteme im Einsatz, keine Kameras. Na dann brauchen wir das Thema... Dann brauchen wir über Malaysia nicht mehr zu reden.
Interessiert ihr überhaupt Malaysia?
Lass mal die Gesichtserkennung weg. Also Gesichtserkennung ist halt echt...
Also mit anderen Worten ist keine Bedrohung oder was? Wie soll ich das jetzt übersetzen lassen?
Ist derzeit eine geringe Bedrohung, wenn man...
Wenn man nicht auf Constanze hört.
Wenn man betrachtet, dass die Lichtverhältnisse und sowas, dass man mit derzeitigen Kameras, die überwachen, kann man halt einfach Ergebnisse, Vergleichsergebnisse kriegen, die bei 50 % liegen. Das ist für eine Identifikation von Leuten einfach unbrauchbar, weil du auf einen positiven Match einen Fehler hast und damit kannst du nicht benutzen. Das heißt nicht, dass nicht trotzdem durch welche Verfahren auch immer, entweder 3D oder die Berechnung oder zusätzliche Verfremdung mit anderen Lichtinformationen, die Erkennungsleistung nicht trotzdem noch gesteigert werden kann. Die Gefahr ist definitiv nicht gebannt, dass man aus Überwachungskameras oder bei Überwachungskameras biometrische Erkennung mit einbaut. Also die wird es auf jeden Fall in Zukunft geben.
Und dann muss man sich auch vorstellen, dass man Altes, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, auch noch kombinieren kann. Etwa 2D, 3G Gesichtserkennung oder man nennt diese Systeme multimodale Systeme. Etwa Fingerabdruck und Gangerkennung oder dergleichen. Wir müssen mal zum Ende kommen.
Ja genau, wir wollten uns ja auf den Elektronischen Reisepass konzentrieren, aber ich denke, was sozusagen die Lehre aus allem ist, was wir jetzt gehört haben, das Problem ist, dass durch diese etwas brutal geführte Sicherheitsdebatte jetzt neue Gesamterfassungskonzepte das Licht des Tages gesehen haben und im Prinzip alle EU-Bürger und über kurz oder lang vielleicht auch alle Bürger auf diesem Planeten über einen biometrischen Pass verfügen oder Personalausweis.
Weil die Amis speichern da 75 Jahre nach dem Tod.
Und die Toten? Okay, das schafft bestimmt komplett neue Anwendungsfälle für, ich weiß nicht, Hollywood und ihre CGI-Farm. Aber vor allem schafft das eine ganze Menge Begehrlichkeiten. Darüber wollte ich vielleicht noch mal abschließend kurz reden, was ihr da noch an möglichen Konsequenzen seht. Wenn die Daten erst mal da sind, dann kommt man eigentlich erst mal so auf die tollen Ideen, wie man das verwenden kann. Was würde dir denn da so einfallen, Constanze?
Die Problematik besteht zum einen darin, dass man halt nur ein Gesicht hat und befindet man sich in biometrischen Datenbanken, mit diesem Gesicht kann man schlecht tauschen. Und auch die Anzahl der Fingerabdrücke ist natürlich begrenzt. Insofern besteht erstmal ein großes Problem gegenüber eben zum Beispiel einem Namen, den man ändern kann. Dann kann man eben die Merkmale, die an dem Körper haften, nicht ändern. Und verbinden tun sich dort Schwierigkeiten mit dem Identitätsklau natürlich, mit der Platzierung von solchen Daten, zum Beispiel an Tatorten.
Aber genau, die Identitätsklau soll das doch eigentlich verhindern. Das ist ja die Argumentation.
Beim Gesicht ist es relativ offensichtlich, man läuft halt mit diesem Gesicht rum den ganzen Tag. Und man wird halt oft gefilmt. Es ist ja nicht verdeckt, anders als der Fingerabdruck, mit dem man ja noch irgendwo aufdrücken muss. Aber auch beim Fingerabdruck ist es natürlich so, dass alle glatten Flächen für menschliche Finger natürlich potenzielle Fingerabdruck-Abnahmeflächen sind, weil man ja immer diese Fettschicht auf der Haut hat und auf allen glatten Flächen einen Fingerabdruck hinterlässt, ohne dass man es so wirklich will.
Das heißt, man ist einfach vielfältig erfassbar. Kann man eigentlich auch Fingerabdrücke erzeugen? Also natürlich, wenn man Fingerabdruckscanner...
Nein, man kann sie generieren. Es gibt Software, die zum Test dieser biometrischen Algorithmen verwendet wird. Man kann sich Fingerabdrücke generieren in verschiedensten Art. Wir hatten gerade die Demonstration gegen Überwachungsstaat.
Die größte Demonstration seit 1984 gegen den Überwachungsstaat.
Da haben wir zum Beispiel auch Fingerabdruck-Attrappen mit selbstgenerierten Fingerabdrücken verteilt, die dann die Leute wofür auch immer verwenden können, um ihre Identität zu schützen.
Man kann sagen, dass sie reißenden Absatz gefunden haben.
Wenn man jetzt kein Interesse an diesen elektronischen Speichersystemen hat und der Pass trotzdem gültig ist, was kann man denn da noch dagegen unternehmen?
Also man kann natürlich erstmal ansetzen, die Daten nicht aufnehmen zu lassen. Also wenn man halt zum Meldeamt geht und seine Fingerdrücke nicht abgeben will, dann kann man halt verschiedene Maßnahmen versuchen. Also erstens versucht man halt irgendwie mit den Meldestellenbappen, sich irgendwie gutzustellen, dass sie sagen, du hast keinen. Oder man kann zum Beispiel auch alle acht Finger in Pflaster oder in Gips packen. Dann heißt das... Das ist so vorgesehen.
Ich stimme gerade solche Horden von Leuten, die alle komplett von unten bis oben eingegipst von Bildern auflaufen.
Entschuldige, man kann doch mal krank sein.
Man kann sich gerade geschnitten haben an allen Fingern.
Der ganze Prenzlauer Berg.
Also ich schneide mich zum Beispiel jede Woche regelmäßig an allen Fingern gucken.
Natürlich. Dann kriegt man... Hast du schon mal überlegt zum Arzt, wie das geht?
Das Leben kann so schön sein, Constanze.
Dann kriegt man halt einen vorübergehenden Reisepass ohne Fingerabdrücke. Das heißt, da kommt man schon mal um die Speicherung der Fingerabdrücke rum. Der ist natürlich nur ein Jahr gültig, aber kann man halt jedes Jahr wieder machen.
Ah, ein Pass ohne Fingerabdrücke ist nur ein Jahr gültig.
Genau, es geht noch in den Vorläufigen, die man so ausstellen kann. Also wenn man halt jetzt wirklich Fingerabdrücke hätte, die man normalerweise abnehmen kann, dann kann man halt entweder versuchen, einen temporären Pass zu kriegen, oder man versucht, den Meldbeamten dazu zu bringen, zu sagen, dass man keine Fingerabdrücke hat. Das kann man natürlich noch unterstützen. Zum Beispiel Sekundenkleber. Man hat halt gerade gebastelt, hat halt Sekundenkleber an, allen acht Fingern, allen wichtigen. Das kann man aber... Man sieht es eventuell nicht, wenn man raufguckt und der Sensor sagt halt, dass es kein gültiger Fingerabdruck ist. Wenn du meinst, das sieht man, dann gibt es halt zum Beispiel noch eine andere Möglichkeit, Ameisensäure. Man kann halt explizit Fingerabdrücke verätzen, das ist auch schmerzfrei. Ja, es ist nahezu schmerzfrei.
Also ich find schon Sekundenkleber auf den Fingern echt nicht schön.
Das wäre doch nicht so ein weicherer, ich bin zufrieden.
Du willst deine Daten nicht beim Start haben, deine Fingerabdruckdaten, das ist einfach mal ein Fakt.
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass es nicht so schön ist, aber egal. Wo kriege ich Ameisensäure her? Gibt es in jeder Apotheke. Ah, okay, ich dachte schon, ich muss mir noch meine eigene Hügel anbauen.
Boah, das tut vielleicht doch weh. Also wir werden auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Fakten dazu ins Netz stellen, wie das explizit dann geht. Der Vorteil mit Ameisensäure ist, dass es wirklich wie eine Hautkrankheit aussieht. Der Meldestellbeamte wird nicht sagen, du versuchst uns hier zu verarschen, du hast Ameisensäure benutzt, sondern es sieht aus, wie wenn du eine Hautkrankheit hast. Der wird gleich beim ersten Mal angucken, der hat keine Fingerdrücke, dann lassen wir ihn mal weg. Du kriegst dann einen zehn Jahre gültigen Pass ohne Fingerdrücke.
Man muss natürlich bedenken, dass es auch noch andere Methoden gibt, aber wir wollen von diesen Raspeln und Pfeilen doch eher abraten, weil es ist doch nicht sehr schmerzfähig. Starbug hat ja selber schon im Eigenversuch feststellen müssen, dass Raspeln und Pfeilen nicht so toll sind.
Ich habe schon ein paar Sachen versucht und die Sachen, die sich als praktikabel herausgestellt haben, sind in der Tat Sekundenkleber oder Ameisensäure.
Also für Frauen empfiehlt sich auch, ich habe noch spezielle Frauentipps, für Frauen empfiehlt sich auch, die Maniküre ihrer Wahl zu nehmen und die Fingernägel so machen zu lassen, dass man es nicht auf die Sensoren auflegen kann.
Ach du meinst diese Bootsausleger-Teile?
Okay, da hat man vielleicht ein paar Wochen echt ein Problem mit dem Leben, aber das sollte einem die 10 Jahre fingerabdruckfrei wert sein.
Also was ich jetzt einfach nur zeigen wollen, ist, dass es tatsächlich Möglichkeiten gibt, auch um die Erfassung der Fingerabdrücke drumrum zu kommen. Wenn das alles nicht hilft und man sich nicht mit Ameisensäure bepunschen will, dann muss man halt schon seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben, aber hat dann natürlich die andere Möglichkeit, das Auslesen der Fingerabdrücke aus dem Pass zu verhindern. Das ist entweder ein temporäres Verhindern, indem man zum Beispiel Alufolie einfach einlegt, um das elektrische Feldsystempass auslesen, das mit Energieversorgung zu minimieren, das nämlich ausgelesen werden kann, oder man kann ihn auch explizit zerstören. Man kann ihn vor allem so zerstören, dass er weiterhin, er ist weiterhin gültig, das ist das Wichtige dabei, und man kann ihn nicht wirklich ansehen, dass er mutwillig zerstört wurde.
Wir haben da immer das Problem, dass wir gefragt werden nach der Mikrowelle. Man sollte ihn also nicht in die Mikrowelle legen, weil diese Brandlauchte auch vielleicht rot. Es gibt natürlich noch eine andere Möglichkeit. Wenn man fähiger Jurist ist, sollte man sich vielleicht endlich mal auch auf den Rechtsweg machen. Wir warten eigentlich immer noch mal darauf, dass hier mal ganz ernsthaft auch juristisch vorgegangen wird. Wir sind nun eine Hacker-Vereinigung, da sind wir gerade mal nicht zuständig.
Was wäre dann der Hebel, den du da sehen würdest, den man mal ausprobieren sollte, ob irgendwas bewegt?
Es ist halt die Frage, insbesondere wenn es für die Personalausweise kommt, ob diese biometrische Vollerfassung eigentlich mit unserem Grundgesetz vereinbar ist. Also ich wäre doch mal sehr gespannt, ob es einen fähigen Juristen gibt, der diese Frage mal durchexerziert.
Also eine Verfassungsschleife.
Man hat jetzt erstmal die Möglichkeit, über diesen EU-Umweg, die sie gegangen sind, zu versuchen, irgendwie das anzugreifen. Also weil es halt auch demokratisch fragwürdig ist. Genau. Dann natürlich, wenn es halt in den Pässen oder in den Ausweisen sind, das heißt, wenn jede Person es abgeben muss, dann hat man auf jeden Fall die Frage, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht schon mal gesagt hat, halt die Personenniziffer im Endeffekt. Weil halt ein biometrisches Merkmal ist halt eine eindeutige Nummer, die halt einer Person zugeordnet ist, was halt eigentlich laut Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil von 83 nicht zulässig ist.
Also wir hoffen doch wirklich mal, dass es jetzt dann passieren wird.
Und wir sind auf jeden Fall auch bereit, also alles, was technische Unterstützung oder irgendwie Aussagen auf der technischen Ebene, werden wir gerne auch bereit, die zu leisten. Wir haben halt bloß die Juristen nicht. Also wir können halt irgendwie nicht die juristischen Auseinandersetzungen führen.
Okay, wenn sich also Juristen und andere Mitstreiter angesprochen fühlen, im EPAS-Projekt des CCC mitzuhelfen.
Nur ernst gemeinte Zuschriften.
Nur ernst gemeinte Zuschriften. www.ccc.de/epashatschon eine Nachrichtenübersicht. Ja, das gibt es. Ich habe eben extra nochmal nachgeschaut. Ihr könnt dann mal sicherstellen, dass da auch aktuelle Informationen stehen. Ansonsten EPAS ccc.de ist eine Möglichkeit, sich direkt mit dem Team in Verbindung zu bringen, wenn es Feedback zur Sendung gibt. Chaosradio ccc.de, wir freuen uns immer. Insbesondere ich hier bei Chaosradio Express. Und ich denke, das war es, die 47. Ausgabe. Vielen Dank, Constanze. Vielen Dank, Starbug. Jetzt haben wir doch schon hier gestandene 2 Stunden 15 Minuten zusammen.
Ich habe immer noch nicht über Malaysia erzählt.
Du hast immer noch nicht über Malaysia erzählt.
Aber wir werden über Malaysia erzählen, denn wir haben doch noch eine Chaosradio-Sendung bei Fritz, die wir vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit hinweisen können.
Ja, die immer noch einmal im Monat stattfindet, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wenn nichts dazwischenkommt.
Und im Oktober kommt nichts dazwischen. Das heißt am 31. Oktober.
Direkt einen Tag vor Einführung der Fingerabdrücke in den Reisepass sind wir on air.
Dazu sollte man sagen...
Das Thema ist Malaysia.
Das Thema ist der Elektronische Reisepass. Und vielleicht komme ich dazu, was über Malaysia zu erzählen.
Ich denke mal schon. Ich finde gerade für die Fritz-Sendung ganz wichtig, da können wir die praktischen Erfahrungen von Malaysia mal schildern.
Also einfach mal Sachen, die uns in der Zukunft auch betreffen werden, die haben es schon mal durchexerziert. Und da sind die Probleme offenbar geworden. Man sollte noch vorher dazu sagen, also der 31. Oktober zur Chaosradio-Sendung ist natürlich schon zu spät, wenn man noch einen alten Reisepass ohne Fingerabdrücke haben will. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt noch einen 10 Jahre gültigen Reisepass mit Gesichtsbild zwar, aber ohne Fingerabdrücke haben will, dann sollte man in den nächsten Wochen auf jeden Fall ins Mellamt gehen. Der ist gültig, damit kann man in die USA einreisen, damit kann man alles so weit machen wie bisher auch. Aber man muss ihn halt bis wahrscheinlich Mitte Oktober beantragt haben, dass er halt noch rechtzeitig ohne Fingerabdrücke ausgestellt wird.
Und wenn man dann den Chip deaktivieren will, kann man zum Kongress dann ja bei uns mal vorbeischauen.
Okay, ihr seht schon, es ist immer angemessen, Chaosradio Express sofort runterzuladen und auch sofort zu hören, weil sonst ist es zu spät, wenn diese Sendung...
Genau.
Wenn es jetzt gerade 2010 ist und ihr endlich auf diese Partei gestoßen seid, dann ist es leider schon zu spät. Okay, das war's. Vielen Dank. Und wir hören uns alle bald wieder bei Chaosradio Express. Bis bald. Tschüss. Tschau.